aujourd'hui on va commencer à rentrer
dans le
de charmantes de la solution au problème
le charbon l'absence de charme plus
exactement
donc si je résume les quelques cours
précédent on a inventé un système
merveilleux de corne d'abondance
merveilleuse qui s'appelle la
civilisation industrielle qui permet
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat qui
permet d'augmenter le temps libre qui
permet d'augmenter la production de tous
les gadgets qui vous passe par la tête
des taxis volant jusqu'au téléphone qui
tiennent tout seul en l'air comme dans
harry potter et puis cette affaire-là se
heurte à au moins deux limites physiques
la première c'est que
l'approvisionnement énergétique fossile
n'est pas infini et la deuxième c'est
que notre activité mais un peu partout
des sous produits indésirables dont des
gaz à effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
qui sont susceptibles d'engendrer des
changements que nous allons trouver
éventuellement pas très sympathique
alors dans la manière de s'attaquer à
exactement d'essayer de résoudre le
problème entre guillemets qui est posée
par la situation actuelle
il y a deux grandes familles de
solutions la première c'est d'essayer de
faire fonctionner un système socialement
stables avec moins d'énergie
c'est ce qu'on va regarder aujourd'hui
la deuxième qu'on va à tout petit peu
regardez aujourd'hui aussi et qu'on
regardera les deux poursuivants c'est
comment est ce que on essaye de faire en
sorte que cette énergie soit disponible
en mettant moins de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère
d'accord donc il ya deux grandes
familles où j'en utilise - où j'essaye
d'en utiliser de la moins carboné donc
le premier débat c'est un débat sur les
économies d'énergie et le deuxième débat
c'est le débat sur tout ce qui est
décarbonation de l'énergie en
particulier renouvelables et nucléaires
c'est les deux les deux grandes familles
de discussion qu'on va voir à partir de
maintenant
par ailleurs il ya quelque chose de
théorique pour les uns et de plus
pratique pour les autres dans cette
discussion parce que comme j'ai essayé
de l'exposer dans les cours précédent
tous les pays vont pas être toutes les
zones non pas être logé à la même
enseigne en ce qui concerne le
calendrier de cette histoire c'est à
dire que j'ai également essayé vous
explique
et que de toute façon même mois pour le
temps qui me reste à vivre et vous pour
tout le temps qu'il vous reste à vivre
de manière absolument certaine ne
pourrait pas ne pourront pas échapper à
quelque chose concernant cette affaire
c'est à dire que soient les économies et
la décarbonation on les gère
soit on les subit mais de toute façon on
passera pas à côté et l'europe
malheureusement pour nous est après le
japon la zone dans le monde qui est le
plus pauvre en ressources énergétiques
du japon n'a rien c'est assez simple
l'europe a encore la mer du nord et du
charbon en pologne et en europe et en
allemagne
mais enfin c'est pas assez pour assurer
une croissance de la quantité d'énergie
disponible à partir de maintenant même
si on se fiche du climat donc il ya une
raison de faire des économies d'énergie
qui est souvent la raison la plus
fréquemment mise en avant dans le débat
médiatique je parlerai un tout petit peu
des médias pendant ce court
qui est il faut faire quelque chose
contre le changement climatique mais il
faut pas oublier qu'il ya de toute façon
une voiture balai dans cette histoire
avec la voiture balai est déjà à
l'oeuvre dans les pays de l' ocde c'est
ce que rappelle ce graphique qui est le
fait que l'approvisionnement énergétique
et déjà contraint pour une partie d
énergie que nous utilisons alors je vous
reprocher tu pas le graphique concernant
l'europe
mais je vous rappelle qu'en ce qui
concerne l'europe l'approvisionnement de
charbon est en déclin climat ou pas
climat l'approvisionnement en pétrole
est en déclin climat ou pas climat et
l'approvisionnement en gaz est en déclin
climat ou pas climat donc on a 80 %
notre approvisionnement qui est de toute
façon en déclin en tendance dans la zone
ocde
vous voyez que depuis 2006 en
l'occurrence depuis 2007 plus tôt
l'approvisionnement est passé par un
maximum et depuis il ne retrouve pas le
chemin de la croissance donc en fait les
le fait de devoir faire fonctionner un
système socialement stables avec moins
d'énergie et déjà une équation qui est
devant nous depuis une dizaine d'années
dans la zone qu'on appelle ocde alors
ocde c'est ce qu'on appelait autrefois
les pays riches c'est à dire l'europe de
l'ouest
l'australie le japon la corée du sud la
turquie toute l'amérique du nord
voilà c'est ça le la zone ocde le en ce
qui concerne la partie amont j'ai envie
de dire la nécessité de faire des
économies
parce que on a déjà un problème sur
l'approvisionnement
pour nous c'est sous notre nez alors
c'est pas souvenez de la population
riche et bien nourris qui dans cette
salle
parce que nous faisons partie pour
mettre un peu les pieds dans le plat
sauf quelques-uns d'entre vous de ce
qu'on appelle les csp + donc c'est les
gens qui sont à l'abri du besoin
ce que vos parents sont pour l'essentiel
enseignants cadres supérieurs etc c'est
ça le sait ça le panorama de l'élève
type notre enseignement supérieur
technique dans ce pays donc vous ne
voyez pas le problème chez vous la
question des économies force et c'est
quelque chose que vous ne voyez pas chez
vous par contre si vous regardez ce qui
est en train de se passer dans les zones
périphériques des villes
depuis dix ans je peux vous assurer que
le problème est déjà alors vous le voyez
pas chez vous encore une fois sauf
exception donc première raison de faire
des économies encore une fois c'est que
de toute façon il va y avoir moins et du
coup confère le premier cours
toutes choses égales par ailleurs il y
aura moins d'économies moins d'énergie
moins de machines -1 pb oui
baisse du revenu augmentation des
inégalités augmentation du chômage et
c'est là que les problèmes de type
économique se concentrent dans cet
endroit là si ou bien les gens ce qu on
appelle les working poor en bon
franglais
c'est à dire les gens qui travaillent
mais qui pour autant n'arrivent pas à
joindre les deux bouts alors en france
avec notre salaire minimum très élevés
et c'est un truc qu'on ne veut qu'on
voit moins ce qu'il faut faire
en gros il faut faire des contrats
jeunes des machins enfin des trucs qui
sont très spécifiques et dérogatoire du
droit commun pour pour arriver le faire
mais dans d'autres pays occidentaux
c'est comme ça que le problème
aujourd'hui c'est comme ça que
l'ajustement se fait aujourd'hui
voilà donc je n'insiste un peu là dessus
parce que encore une fois très souvent
quand on parle des économies d'énergie
ou d autres marge de manoeuvre que nous
avons face aux changements climatiques
on continue à voir ça comme quelque
chose qu'il faudrait se décider à faire
la semaine prochaine pour éviter des
gros emmerdements en 2050
j'insiste beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup sur
le fait que en europe c'est déjà plus
une option les économies on les fait de
toute façon déjà en europe
la deuxième raison de faire des
économies
c'est donc la question du changement
climatique alors je vous montre ici à un
graphique je crois pas vouloir de vérité
je crois pas vous avoir montré la
dernière fois ce graphique il vous dit
il vous superposent tout un tas de
simulation faite avec des modèles de
climat est restituée dans le dernier
rapport complet du giec et engrossé
simulation elle vous donne en abscisse
les émissions cumulées de co2 au cours
du temps et en ordonnée la réponse en
température du système en fonction des
émissions cumulées de co2 ce que vous
voyez en gros c'est qu'on a affaire à
une droite et les émissions pardon et
l'élévation de température c'est
l'élévation de température entre l'ère
préindustrielle et de 1110 autrement
avec l'inertie du co2 dans l'atmosphère
c'est l'élévation de température
embarqué dans les émissions qui ont déjà
eu lieu c'est comme ça qu'il faut lire
le graphique
donc si par exemple on s'arrête aux
émissions d'aujourd'hui aux émissions
cumulées d'aujourd'hui qui font à peu
près de 1200 milliards de tonnes de co2
eh bien nous avons embarqué 1,5 degrés
de réchauffement alors jamais dire
jamais comment ça se fait puisque dans
les accords de paris on a dit qu'on
allait faire tout ce qu'on pouvait pour
limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 degré
donc si on l'a déjà avec ce qu'on a déjà
émis pourquoi est-ce qu'on com pourquoi
est-ce qu'on discuterait de le limiter à
1,5 plus tard puisque de toute façon on
peut plus rien faire il ya déjà là j'y
reviendrai juste après mais en gros si
on arrête les émissions demain matin ce
que vous disent ce que vous dise
ce graphique c'est que on comprend en
gros 1 5° à la fin du siècle si on veut
limiter le réchauffement à 2 degrés à la
fin du siècle
à ce moment on fait le chemin inverse et
ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il faut limiter
les émissions à 3000 milliards de tonnes
de co2 dont 2200 déjà été émise donc en
gros ça veut dire que il faut limiter
les émissions pour la partie du siècle
qui reste donc entre maintenant et 2100
à 800 milliards de tonnes de co2 c'est à
dire en première approximation le tiers
de ce qui a été émis pendant le siècle
qui a précédé avec une population en
moyenne trois fois moins nombreuses ce
qui veut dire que le droit à émettre de
chacun d'entre vous sur ce qui vous
reste à vivre
si je fais cette règle de trois jusqu'au
bout c'est le 9e du droit à émettre pour
hugo grands parents jusqu'au moment où
ils sont morts
alors c'est à peu près ça
le résultat de la règle de trois alors
vous comprenez que effectivement si on
veut faire quoi que ce soit d'approchant
de cette limite
il va falloir s'occuper en particulier
de la quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise
d'où une deuxième justification en ce
qui concerne des économies d'énergie
alors je vous disais à 25 degrés avec
les émissions passées on est à peu près
sûr de les avoir
2 les avoirs de toute façon alors c'est
un tout petit peu plus compliqué que ça
ce que vous voyez ici c'est 4
trajectoire des missions qui permettent
de limiter le réchauffement à 1,5 degré
à la fin du siècle
est ce que vous voyez c'est que toutes
ces trajectoires des missions en gros ce
qu'elle vous dise c'est tout ce qu'on
aura émis à partir de maintenant et
jusqu'au moment où les émissions maîtres
deviennent nul derrière il faut que ça
soit compensée par des émissions
négatives du autrement par de la
séquestration m pour compenser le
surplus qu'on a transitoirement mise au
vert
d'accord dont on a le droit d'utiliser
l'atmosphère comme un stock tampon
pendant quelques dizaines d'années pour
rajouter du co2 dans à condition que
derrière on commence à le retirer en met
j'assistais en est ça veut dire qu'à ce
moment là
non seulement il faut plus qu'il y ait
une source de co2 dans le monde
ou en tout cas plus beaucoup mais en
plus il faut que ce qu'on avait déjà mis
dans le passé on le retient de
l'atmosphère et alors on le retire de
l'atmosphère avec deux marges de
manoeuvre qui porte les acronymes très
sympathique non ce graphique qui
s'appelle à polluer behe ccs alors à
faux lui ça veut dire à forer station
and land use dit autrement c'est le
changement d'usagé des sols c'est le
fait de transformer des sols qui ne
capte pas de carbone en sol qui captent
du carbone c'est ça qu'on appelle un
faux lui donc c'est soir faut rester des
terres qu'ils n'avaient pas de forêt et
à ce moment le fait que vous créiez un
stock de forêt en stock de biomasse
s'avoue transfert du carbone de
l'atmosphère vers le sol ou bien vous
changez vos pratiques agricoles et à ce
moment par exemple vous labouré moins à
ce moment vous remettez du carbone dans
le sol voilà c'est ça pollue et bo ccsc
bailleur massey energy avec 4 carbon
capture dit autrement c'est des
centrales électriques au bois et vous
capturer le co2 je vais vous en parler
plus tard en cours et vous leur mettez
sous terre donc dit autrement la forêt
capte du co2 de l'atmosphère
vous prenez le bois donc le carbone est
passé de l'atmosphère dans le bois vous
prenez le bois vous le faites brûler
dans une centrale électrique et le co2
de la centrale électrique vous le
capturer et vous le mettez sous terre
donc vous avez fait la totalité du
chemin inverse
atmosphère vert sous sol que aujourd'hui
on fait dans l'autre sens combustibles
fossiles layrac mosphere donc sous sol
vers l'atmosphère
voilà donc je vous détaille pas le jeu
vous détaille pas à chacun des quatre
scénarios mais vous voyez que en gros
dans l'esprit ce qu'on a mis dans
l'atmosphère jusqu'en 2050 il faut le
retirer derrière alors celui là il
s'arrête en 2100 mais derrière 2100 il
faut continuer à séquestrer en est donc
l'idée c'est que en gros je le redis
encore autrement pour limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degrés en 2100 il
faudrait qu'on s'arrête des maîtres
demain matin ce qui n'est pour le moment
pas le cas si on veut limiter à 2 degrés
donc là c'est pas demain matin qu'il
faut s'arrêter des maîtres mais à peu
près vous avez à ce moment et c'est ça
qui va me servir de
de référence dans un calcul que je vous
ferai plus tard vous avez ici la
trajectoire des missions là c'est juste
sur le co2 qui font respecter pour tenir
la limite des 2 degrés alors il se
trouve qu'aujourd'hui si on rajoute les
autres gaz à effet de serre au co2 on
est à peu près à 60 milliards de tonnes
équivalent co2 des missions par an et il
faudrait qu'on soit aux alentours de 20
en 2050 si on suit ce scénario bas qui
lui permet d'avoir alors quand je dis en
fait de limiter à 2 degrés c'est une
approche probabiliste
c'est mon sommeil gaussienne dont je
parlais l'avant dernière fois et donc
ces deux chances sur trois de limiter le
réchauffement à 2 degrés avec cette
trajectoire là on a déjà une chance sur
trois d'excéder les deux degrés parce
que je rappelle qu'il ya une barre
d'erreurs dans les simulations
climatiques et donc il n'y a pas de
résultat qui est absolument garanti
quand on regarde l'avenir commence et
les ordres de grandeur voilà donc
retenez que d'ici à ce que vous ayez mon
âge si on veut limiter le réchauffement
à 2 degrés il faut que les émissions
planétaires soit divisé par trois ses
salles ordre de grandeur qu'il faut
avoir en tête
si on n'est pas capable de limiter les
émissions par trois ans disent y est ce
que vous ayez mon âge c'est absolument
certain donc je peux parier la totalité
de mes économies plus celle de qui veut
je serai pas là pour voir le résultat
mes enfants si normalement qu' on ne
tiendra pas les 2 degrés parce que tout
ça est une affaire encore une fois de
réchauffement embarqués et de grande
durée de vie du co2 dans les abris
attrayante discontinuité
ah oui à l'échelle géologique bien sûr
oui
non alors il ya deux choses qui sont
distinctes gelé ou quand je la captation
du co2 je vais vous expliquer dans une
heure ou à peu près en quoi ça consiste
techniquement celle qu'on envisage
aujourd'hui c'est la captation du co2
fossile donc en gros vous avez un
combustible fossile que vous retirer du
sous sol
vous brûlez et le co2 au lieu de laisser
partir dans l'atmosphère voulu récupérer
vous leur mettez dans le sous sol
donc là vous avez une opération blanche
on va dire mais ça ne vous diminue pas
la quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère
ça vous empêche simplement d'augmenter
si vous voulez la diminuer à ce moment
il faut récupérer le co2 de l'atmosphère
avec des plantes brûler les plantes
prendre le co2 de la combustion des
plantes capturés et celui là le mètres
sous le sol
et à ce moment vous avez fait en gros ce
que la géologie a fait 150 millions
d'années quand elle a fait du pétrole
c'est là qu'elle a retiré du co2
atmosphérique et elle l'a collé sous le
sol sous forme de stock de carbone
voilà c'est ça le bébé au ccs dans ce
que j'évoquais avant c'est très
exactement ça donc c'est un moyen en
gros de passer l'aspirateur à co2 dans
l'atmosphère mais c'est un moyen qui
marche sur le papier je vous montrerai
après tout les limites qui font que
malheureux sommes prêts à parier qu'il
va y avoir ça partout dans les 30 ans
qui viennent
voilà donc retenez les ordres de
grandeur
c'est une division par trois en l'espace
d'une génération une génération et demi
qu'il faut faire pour tenir les 2 degrés
il faut garder cette de grandeur en tête
oui
parce que s'ils voulaient brûler sans
remettre le co2 sous le sol de co2
repart dans l'atmosphère donc à nouveau
vous avez une opération blanche
pardon si on les brûle pas vous avez pas
d'énergie donc là l'idée c'est de les
utiliser à la place du charbon ou du gaz
ou de n'importe quoi d'autre pour faire
de l'électricité
oui mais s'ils se décompose tout seuls
dans leur coin vous n'avez pas d'énergie
donc là en fait c'est un procédé qui est
destiné à remplacer en particulier dans
la génération électrique le charbon et
le gaz
donc l'idée c'est que au lieu de
déstocker du carbone du sous-sol et de
mettre le co2 dans l'atmosphère vous
fait le chemin inverse en utilisant de
la biomasse dont vous capturer le co2 de
combustion pour le remettre sous le sol
mais s'il ya d'autres questions
là-dessus renvoyer à tout à l'heure
parce que je vous en parler plus en
détail
je vous emporte tout à l'heure c'est pas
lui alors le pour vous donner une idée
de ce que représente la contrepartie des
missions divisé par trois pour neuf
milliards d'individus
on peut faire une petite règle de trois
la petite règle de trois ailes vous dis
donc 20 milliards de tonnes de co2 / 3 /
pardon part aux six milliards
d'individus ça vous ferait trois tonnes
de co2 par personne
et si vous divisez par neuf ce qui est
plutôt la taille de la population à
l'horizon de 20 ans
eh bien on est plutôt à 2 tonnes de co2
par personne alors la question c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec deux tonnes de
co2 est bien avec deux tonnes de co2
vous faites votre stage à l'étranger que
la direction des études vous demande de
faire
et puis le reste de l'année vous n'avez
pas le droit de vivre vous pouvez pas
manger vous pouvez pas voter parce que
là dedans vous avez déjà les émissions
liées à l'alimentation
donc vous avez vous pouvez pas manger
vous pouvez pas vous vêtir vous pouvez
pas acheter une brosse à dents vous
pouvez pas vous déplacer
rien d'accord vous avez pris l'avion
terminée alors vous allez me dire quoi
comment je vous rappelle que les
déplacements en avion
c'est quelque chose qui est extrêmement
récents dans l'histoire des hommes
en 1950 il y avait les boxeurs célèbre
et les stars de cinéma et les ministres
qui se déplaçait en avion ça s'arrêtait
là hmm hmm hmm l'élève aux mines
il ya cinquante ans ils prenaient pas
l'avion ça n'existait pas mon père qui a
étalé comme post-doc aux états unis il
est allé en fait tout donc c'est quelque
chose qui est extrêmement récent envoyé
un voleur avions crack vous avez
travaillé votre quota après c'est
terminé vous avez la possibilité de
consommer quelques milliers à quelques
dizaines de milliers oui
là
ça pollue beaucoup plus si vous faites
le même kilométrage annuel en plusieurs
vols
c'est pire que de le faire en un seul
vol parce que ce qu'ils consomment
beaucoup de carburant
proportionnellement c'est le décollage
oui sauf que même si vous faites mille
kilomètres au bout de vingt kilomètres
votre avion il ya quasiment un même un
vol de 1000km votre avion il monte il
monte au plafond des 10 villes mettre
très vite il reste pas il reste pas à
300 mètres d'altitude
oui
oui sauf que vous prenez jamais l'avion
pour aller d'ici jusqu'à saclay quoi
donc en fait quand vous montez dans
l'avion vous savez que vous allez toute
façon faire entre 1000 et 2000 km c'est
à ça que ça sert en fait ce qui va oui
ça dépend quel type de bateau si vous
prenez le queen mary c'est encore pire
donc ils vont entendre y aller en avion
par contre si vous êtes passager
supplémentaire sur un cargo de banane
c'est parfait non mais c'est exactement
ça donc ça dépend ça dépendra à quoi
sert le bateau en gros mais s'il sert
juste à transporter des croisiéristes
retraités avec un membre d'équipage pour
deux passagers etc
c'est encore pire que l'avion voilà donc
je continue donc dans on a le droit de
consommer quelques milliers à quelques
dizaines de milliers de kilowattheures
d'électricité alors le là on va en
parler aux deux prochains cours
évidemment le mode de production
d'électricité conditionne très largement
le quota en question et du coup ce que
vous voyez ici en filigrane c'est que
évidemment il ya plein de gens qui
rêvent d'un monde dans lequel on
pourrait produire plein d'électricité
décarbonée à ce moment on peut avoir
plein de kilowattheures et on est
capable de substituer plaint d' usage
d'accord on se met à faire fonctionner
l'industrie les transports confort
thermique des bâtiments etc avec de
l'électricité sans carbone et on a entre
guillemets résolu notre problème on en
parle dans les deux prochaines fois vous
avez le droit d'acheter de quelques
kilos à quelques dizaines de kilos de
produits manufacturés avec mes deux
tonnes par exemple avec mes deux tonnes
j'ai le droit d'acheter quatre
ordinateurs comme ça ou quatre écrans de
télévision connectée chez moi d'accord
donc si une année vous achetez un
ordinateur et un écran de télévision
vous avez cramer la moitié de votre
quota rien qu'avec ça vous avez
également le droit d'acheter quelques
milliers d'euros de services factures de
téléphone
agios bancaires places de cinéma donc
vous voyez que là aussi si vous utilisez
si par exemple vous achetez quelques
kilos ou dizaines de kilos de vêtements
tables chaises ordinateurs etc
à ce moment vous mangez plus ou déplacée
plus au chaud fait plus ou etc
vous avez le droit de vous faire
construire un quart de chambre à coucher
m² en structure béton dans un logement
collectif dans un immeuble de type
appartement demande l'émission de 3 à
400 kg de co2 alors construire un mètre
carré dont 4,2 tonnes
nous on construise et 5,6 voilà c'est
l'ordre de grandeur ce qui veut
également dire que l'année où un ménage
se fait construire une maison de 90 m²
et la taille classique d'une maison et
bien cette année là le ménage a émis 35
tonnes de co2 au titre de la
construction de son logement alors ses
émissions c'est celle des cimenteries
des aciéries qu'il a fallu faire
fonctionner pour faire le gros oeuvre de
la maison des briques des tuiles des
fenêtres du câblage électrique et là
dedans je ne tiens pas compte de la
machine à laver d'écrans connectés qu'on
met à l'intérieur vous avez la
possibilité d'utiliser du gaz moins que
de l'électricité en france plus que de
l'électricité dans un pays dans lequel
l'électricité est très carbonées c'est
pour ça que les gaziers et les
électriciens se battent comme des
chiffonniers en permanence et enfin vous
avez la possibilité de faire quelques
milliers de kilomètres en voiture et
tout ça c'est des ou exclusifs
donc si vous partez deux fois en
vacances dans l'année en voiture vous ne
mangez plus vous ne vous habillez plus
vous ne vous chauffer plus vous
n'achetez plus rien et vous ne prenez
pas l'avion pour aller faire un stage à
l'étranger
voilà donc ça oui
mais
j'espérais amoussou enfin tendu
oui beaucoup moins le train il est en
gros alors ça dépend de la manière dont
on fait l'électricité mais en gros un
kilomètre passager en avion c'est de
l'ordre de 150 grammes de co2 un
kilomètre passager en train en france en
fonction du fait que vous considériez
l'infrastructure amorties ou pas amorti
et c'est ça se balade entre quelques
grammes et quelques dizaines de grammes
mais c'est en france
si vous allez en allemagne ça peut
monter à quelques dizaines de grammes à
cause du contenu carbone de
l'électricité mais ça reste toujours
inférieure à l'avion dans tous les cas
de figure
donc ça aussi c'est pour vous faire
toucher du doigt dont quand on dit
diviser par trois les émissions bon très
bien c'est important ça c'est pour vous
faire toucher du doigt à quel point
aujourd'hui nous sommes à des années
lumières avec les habitudes que nous
avons d'avoir quoi que ce soit qui
puisse ressembler à une empreinte
carbone qui soit compatible avec le
monde des 2 degrés qui est par ailleurs
la promesse politique de tout un chacun
en ce moment qu'un tout petit sujet et
je reviendrai tout à fait à la fin de
secours pour pour vous montrer quelques
quelques écarts une des manières qu'ont
à d'économiser de l'énergie
c'est d'améliorer l'efficacité de la
chaîne énergétique du système
énergétique
oui
beaucoup plus
non gala en 2002 mv2 donc ça change pas
donc si vous avez une plus grosse masse
et le plus grosse vitesse c'était plus
un plus gros moteur
ça compte le plus c'est pour ça que soit
dit en passant la tendance actuelle qui
est d'alourdir les voitures et de vendre
des suv à tout le monde c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui est totalement
antinomique avec le fait de s'occuper
sérieusement la question qui m'a donc je
je revenais à ce que je disais à partir
du moment où on a envie de gagner sur la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise une des
choses qu'on peut imaginer de faire
c'est d'améliorer le rendement d'enfin
la chaîne qui va de l'énergie qu'on
trouve dans la nature à l'énergie qui
rentre dans une machine ou même qui nous
rend un service
alors il ya trois termes qui sont
fréquents dans le monde énergétique
qu'il faut avoir en tête le premier
terme ou premier adjectif c'est primaire
l'énergie primaire c'est l'énergie telle
qu'on la trouve dans la nature je vous
ai dit au premier cours que à cause de
la loi de conservation de l'énergie
tout ce qu'on pouvait faire avec cette
grandeur c'était de trouver dans la
nature de l'énergie déjà existantes et
de s'en servir à d'autres profite donc
il faut qu'elle existe cette énergie est
donc cette énergie encore une fois quand
elles existent elles s'appellent
primaire alors dans l'énergie primaire
on va trouver tout ce qui brûle charbon
pétrole bois gaz etc
on va trouver la force des éléments par
exemple la force l'eau qui tombe le vent
qui souffle on va trouver du rayonnement
électromagnétique le soleil on pourrait
si on savait brancher les machines à
laver sur les éclairs d'orage trouver
d'électricité pour non c'est pas bien
voilà donc c'est tout ce qu'on trouve
dans la nature et qui est une source
d'énergie possible cette énergie
primaire va alimenter notre système
énergétique donc le système énergétique
que dans les statistiques qu'on appelle
parfois aussi industries de l'énergie
c'est la même chose c'est tout
l'appareil industriel que nous avons
créé et qui ne sert à rien d'autre que
d'extraire de l'énergie primaire de
l'environnement et d'en faire de
l'énergie qu'on appelle final c'est à
dire qu'il va pouvoir alimenter une
machine hors du système énergétique
alors une machine hors du système
énergique c'est quoi ces 1
vaisselle un aspirateur une voiture un
projecteur de cinéma ou un saut de
tonnes pour se contente pas bien tout ça
c'est des machines qui sont alimentés
par de l'énergie qui sort du système
énergétique
le système énergétique il est lui aussi
loomis où me pardon à la loi de
conservation de l'énergie
donc la loi de conservation de l'énergie
vous dit que l'énergie finale qui
sortent du système c'est au plus égale à
l'énergie primaire et en fait ça sera
toujours inférieure à l'énergie primaire
les pertes que vous pouvez avoir
quand vous passez danger viendrait après
quand vous passez du système primaire au
système final peuvent être extrêmement
élevé et en tout état de cause les
sanctions supérieures à 0 % après il ya
une autre forme d'énergie dont on parle
parfois qui est ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie utile c'est-à-dire celle qui
vous rend vraiment un service
alors je prends l'exemple d'un frigo le
frigo il utilise une énergie finale de
l'électricité par contre il a lui-même
un rendement parce que ce qui vous
intéresse en ce qui concerne le frigo
c'est pas qu'ils consomment de
l'électricité c'est qu'ils vous extraits
des calories de l'intérieur du frigo
comme ça vous êtes sûr que votre bière
est toujours aux frais donc l'énergie
utile dans cette histoire c'est
l'énergie de refroidissement de la bière
très accessoirement tout le reste de ce
qui se trouve dans le frigo vous avez
encore dans cette histoire donc un
rendement de conversion entre finale et
utile c'est pareil quand vous avez
quelqu'un qui se déplace dans une
voiture l'énergie utile c'est soit
l'énergie de déplacement du bo dame donc
il ya l'ami de lv2 appliquée aux badham
soit à l'arrière eux il yal'envie de mv2
appliqué à la voiture c'est beaucoup
moins que l'énergie finale qu'on a mis
dans le réservoir de la voiture
alors les pertes se baladent n'importe
où entre 5 et 75% pour primaire vert
final 75 % typiquement c'est les
turbines à combustion qu'on utilise pour
l'hyper points dans un réseau électrique
et qui sont en gros des moteurs d'avion
et ça ça à des rendements qui sont 20 25
30 % d'accord alors c'est des trucs dont
on conserve 2 à 2 200 heures mon année
c'est pas un paquet que c'est pas très
grave que c'est un mauvais en 5 % c'est
dans les très bons cas de figure quand
vous avez j'ai pas une éolienne avec
très peu de frottement ou bien un
barrage avec très peu de flottement
et puis entre les deux vous avez toute
la gamme et dès que vous faites de
l'électricité avec une machine de carnot
donc dès que vous faites de
l'électricité avec de la chaleur qui
derrière va faire tourner un alternateur
à ce moment vous avez un rendement qui
ne dépassent jamais en cycle simple 45%
qui peut plus quelquefois quand vous
êtes en cycle combiné sur le gaz vous
pouvez atteindre 55 60 que vous avez
deux cycles différents mais sur un cycle
simple vous pouvez vous dépassez
rarement 45% et le rendement moyen d'une
centrale à charbon dans le monde est le
même que le rendement moyen d'une
centrale nucléaire dans le monde
c'est-à-dire un tiers en gros un dans la
transformation finale vers utile là
aussi vous avez des pertes importantes
par exemple dans un moteur de voiture
vous avez des pertes qui peuvent
atteindre jusqu'à 80 % ce qui évidemment
vous avez jamais vous avez jamais un
rendement de 1
plus vous êtes en or de la plage
optimale de régime les moteurs sont
ajustés pour des plages optimale de
régime et plus haut rendement est
mauvais
donc je l'air après une façon de faire
des économies c'est de dire je vais
optimiser cette chaîne est comme ça pour
la même quantité d'énergie utile à
l'arrivée par exemple la même quantité
de bière refroidi dans le frigo je vais
utiliser beaucoup moins d'énergie
primaire et du coup je vais mettre moins
de co2 dans l'atmosphère est moins
dépendre des stocks d'énergie fossile
quand donc l'optimisation de cette
chaîne est un moyen d'économiser de
l'énergie
prenons un exemple voilà une partie de
l'approvisionnement énergétique allemand
est ce que quelqu'un sait ce que c'est
que ça
vous avez quelle hauteur ça fait à peu
près un peu moins est ce que vous savez
retrouver will bulldozer sur la photo
c'est exactement le bulldozer
je veux dire cette petite rue john key
et la tasse et un bulldozer d'accord
alors ça c'est une excavatrice aline it
qui sauf erreur de ma part se trouvent
dans la mine de hambach
en pologne la mine de lignite la plus
profonde en allemagne est de 300 mètres
sous le niveau de la mer
c'est un truc qui fait 5 km sur 5 km et
vous avez un truc comme ça au milieu qui
vous extrait la limite qui est un
charbon jeunes donc riche en eau est
riche en cendres qui va alimenter une
centrale à charbon
voici une centrale à charbon je n'y
reviendrai la prochaine fois mais je
vous rappelle que les tours
réfrigérantes ne sont pas l'apanage des
centrales nucléaires c'est juste
l'apanage des centrales thermiques en
bordure de rivière
il avait plein de centrales nucléaires
en france qui n'ont pas ce genre de tour
toutes celles qui sont en bord de mer et
vous avez plein de centrales à charbon
qui sont en bord de rivière et qui ont
ce genre de tous
quand vous allez de de la limite vers
l'électricité
vous avez des pertes importantes et donc
vous allez retrouver simplement 30 à 45
% du contenu énergétique de votre limite
sous forme d'électricité
après vous allez transporter
l'électricité jusqu'à un endroit vous en
servez là vous allez perdre de l'ordre
de 8% après vous allez mettre ça dans un
frigo alors là en l'occurrence il se
trouve que le frigo j'ai pris un exemple
un peu taquin parce que c'est une pompe
à chaleur donc c'est un rendement
thermodynamique supérieur à 1 et votre
énergie utile c'est ce qui va vraiment
permettre de refroidir ce qui se
trouvera dans le frigo
là vous êtes typiquement sur un exemple
ou de bout en bout le rendement peut
être pas très éloigné de un parce que le
kop d'un frigo c'est 2 3
donc ça peut être pas très éloigné de 1
quand vous allez du primaire vers
l'utile maintenant je prends un autre
exemple on va partir du pétrole
donc voici un endroit où on récupère du
pétrole de terre et quand vous récupérer
le pétrole de terre vous avez déjà une
perte parce que vous avez besoin
d'énergie pour pomper le pétrole
d'accord et l'extraire de terre en fête
l'énergie qui est nécessaire au pompage
du pétrole de terre dans les mauvais cas
de figure ça atteint jusqu'à un tiers du
contenu énergétique du pétrole pompé
dans les dents les mauvais pétrole de
schiste entre guillemets là où vous avez
besoin d'eux
2 vous avez besoin de beaucoup fracturé
beaucoup pompe est derrière avec pas de
temps de pétrole que ça récupère et ça
peut être de l'ordre du tiers dans les
sables bitumineux au canada vous êtes
aussi à des rendements qui sont de cet
ordre là vous avez besoin en gros de
perdre un tiers de l'énergie en cours de
route ensuite ce pétrole va être raffiné
quand on raffine du pétrole vous en
perdez 15%
parce que halo raffinage c'est une
distillation distillation c'est comme
pour le cognac réchauffer et donc vous
allez perdre une partie de l'énergie
contenue dans le pétrole initial pour
effectuer cette distillation et avoir
des produits raffinés vous allez mettre
ces produits raffinés dans une voiture
dont le rendement est de 20 à 40%
et avec ça vous allait transporter un
bonhomme alors si vous considérez que
l'énergie utile c'est pas l'énergie
cinétique de la voiture mais c'est
l'énergie cinétique du bonhomme
parce qu'après tout si on pouvait se
déplacer à 80 km heure sans risque d'en
mourir parce qu'on avait une bonne
carapace sur nous et en écoutant votre
musique préférée sans avoir besoin d'une
voiture va peut-être qu'on pourrait
considérer que l'énergie utile c'est
juste nos 70 ou 60 ou 80 kg qui se
déplace à 80 km/heure n'est pas
l'énergie cinétique de la voiture donc
là vous voyez même si vous vous arrêtez
là vous avez quand même un rendement de
chêne qui est assez bas et évidemment la
tentation est toujours de se dire c'est
pas la peine d'en liquider le
consommateur qui achète une voiture on
va embaucher les bons ingénieurs des
mines qui vont bien et on va leur
demander de travailler là dessus
là dessus et là dessus ça tombe bien il
y en a plein chez les affreux pétrolier
est plein chez les autres constructeurs
et on va leur demander de se creuser un
peu les méninges et nous optimiser tout
ça quand on voit les pourcentages encore
une fois c'est quelque chose qu'on ce
dont on se dit c'est normal
alors c'est normal sauf que vous avez
ici quand vous pomper du pétrole en
provenance d'une roche poreuse
vous luttez contre la capillarité 1 et à
un moment
il ya des rendements enfin je veux dire
vous pouvez pas aller à un rendement
c'est juste pas possible
vous avez des barrières physiques et en
fait ça a plutôt tendance à se dégrader
au cours du temps ici parce que les
gisements qu'on exploite les nouveaux
gisements qu'on trouve sont plutôt moins
sympathique que les anciens là vous êtes
limités par la quantité d'énergie qu'il
faut pour distiller donc c'est pareil
vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas être à
zéro perte
là vous avez une machine de cardo donc
c'est pareil vous pouvez pas être à zéro
perte et vous ne pouvez même pas
améliorée de manière absolument
considérable le rendement des moteurs
donc c'est une tentation forte quand on
voit ce genre de chiffres mais il faut
bien voir qu'il ya souvent des règles
des lois physiques qui limite par
construction les rendements et c'est pas
nécessairement très simple d'aller très
au delà je vais un peu élargir le
raisonnement que j'ai commencé à tenir
en dix ans et tente c'est tentant de
regarder comment est ce que on peut
optimiser les les rendements physique la
grande famille d'économie d'énergie qui
est celle vers laquelle vont toujours en
première approche tous les gens qui
s'intéressent à la question c'est
l'efficacité énergétique alors
l'efficacité énergétique consiste à
obtenir exactement le même service en
améliorant les rendements de chaîne de
bout en bout donc typiquement j'ai une
voiture qui est toujours la même avec
laquelle je parcours toujours elle a
fait le même poids elle fait la même
puissance je parcours toujours la même
distance mais j'ai demandé à messieurs
peugeot renault
enfin renault fiat chrysler maintenant
et consorts de se creuser la cervelle
pour que ça consomme moins de carburant
quand je fais tout ça et donc à
l'arrivée comme je vais pas faire plus
de kilomètres
enfin c'est ce que je dis et que je vais
pas acheter une voiture plus grosse
c'est ce que je dis eh bien je vais
avoir le même service avec moins
d'énergie
donc ça c'est l'efficacité du dollar m
de la même manière dans le logement si
j'ai le même espace habitable et que je
demande à une société que je ne nommerai
pas
isoler correctement mon logement et à
une autre société que je ne nommerai pas
de me faire une chaudière à condensation
et etc
j'aurai le même confort thermique en
ayant utilisé moins d'énergie alors ça
c'est le l'efficacité voilà et ça marche
également évidemment pour les produits
que j'achète
si les industriels ces affreuses
industriels pollueurs
eh bien il va veut faire les mêmes
produits en ayant utilisé moins
d'énergie eh bien j'ai résolu une partie
de mon problème j'ai pas été obligé de
toucher à la consommation une autre
famille d'économie d'énergie c'est
l'exact inverse
je ne demande pas à l'industriel de
faire des progrès et je ne demande pas à
ma voiture des plus efficaces je décide
délibérément d'avoir moins de services
donc de conduire moins de kilomètres
d'acheter moins de produits etc et ce
truc là
ça s'appelle la sobriété donc la
sobriété en gros c'est je m'auto inflige
une limitation de ce que je consomme
évidemment si je ne consomme pas il n'y
a pas besoin de le fabriquer et à ce
moment on a les économies d'énergie
correspondante au fait que je n'ai pas
eu besoin de le fabriquer il ya une
variante de la sobriété qui est celle
qui arrive sans qu'on me demander mon
avis et ça s'appelle la pauvreté donc la
pauvreté c'est tout simplement j'ai une
limite qui s'impose à moi et qui
m'empêche de consommer et à ce moment
évidemment on économise l'énergie qu'il
est nécessaire ou qui étaient
nécessaires à ce que je consommais avant
la grande différence entre la sobriété
et la pauvreté
donc c'est pas physique dans les deux
cas de figure je vais moins consommer
mais dans le premier cas je le désire et
dans le deuxième cas je ne désire pas
donc évidemment dans le premier cas ça
se gère socialement plus simplement que
dans le deuxième
parce que quand le désirent un truc
c'est quand même socialement un peu plus
simple que quand je ne désire pas mais
un truc essentiel à avoir en tête c'est
que dans les deux cas de figure que ce
soit sobriété où pauvreté c'est récessif
parce que du coup on fabrique plus donc
on ne produit plus donc le bout du pib
qui correspondait à la production
disparaît
donc la sobriété est quelque chose qui
marche de manière généralisée
à partir du moment où on accepte l'idée
que ça va avec le fait de faire
décroître de pib tel qu'il a été conçu
soit dit en passant parce qu'au moment
où il a été conçu le pib s'était
vraiment pour mesurer des chasses des
chaises pardon des tables et les verts
et faire décroître le pib j'en parlerai
un peu plus tard quand on parlera de
systèmes hérités l'envi sa toute petite
conséquence de court terme c'est que ça
fait décroître la base fiscale et donc
que vous n'allez pas voir à peu près un
élu sauf rares exceptions qui se
présente devant les caméras en disant
c'est ça qui fait faire parce que ça lui
crée immédiatement à problèmes
budgétaires de court terme qui sait pas
résoudre
donc la quasi totalité du monde
politique n'envisage absolument pas de
généraliser ces deux trucs là par
ailleurs généraliser ces deux trucs là
suppose d'embarquer la totalité des
consommateurs alors que de s'occuper de
ça ça suffit juste de taper sur la tête
de quelques industriels et quelques
ingénieurs des mines
donc c'est quand même en terme de
population on met sous contrainte
beaucoup plus petit numériquement et
comme dans les démocraties chaque
personne a un bulletin de vote
quelle que soit sa position en général
toute solution qui permet de minimiser
le nombre de gens sur lequel vous avez
besoin de taper pour régler un problème
est une solution préférentiels donc il
ya très très peu de discours sur les
deux casses du banc alors maintenant
pour revenir au début de secours à
partir du moment où on accepte l'idée
qu'au plus pour des raisons géologiques
l'approvisionnement énergétique b sera
de toute façon il est assez simple de
comprendre que tout ce qu'on ne fera pas
au titre de ça et de ça on le fera au
titre de ça c'est très simple un g3
tiroir de la commode
donc tout ce qu'on ne réussit pas à
faire au titre de l'efficacité ou de la
sobriété se fera sous forme de pauvreté
et donc ça renvoie à la question vous
m'avez posée au début de secours qui est
où est ce que ça se passe eh bien ça se
passe déjà en pas payer sous contrainte
énergétique
là vous voyez augmenter les poches de
pauvreté et d'inégalité etc
c'est là que ça se passe aujourd'hui
vous projetez ça après primaire finale
ici vous avez tout simplement le
diagramme primaire finale de la france
dans lequel vous voyez ici donc les
énergies primaires qu'on utilise ici les
énergies finale qu'on utilise ce que
vous voyez c'est que sur le pétrole ya
très peu de pertes intermédiaire sur
l'électricité primaire il y en a
énormément parce que c'est de la chaleur
perdue
voilà c'est le essentielle ment salle
l'idée a jeté en détail dans le monde
la conversion primaire vert final nous
fait perdre
en gros je dis bien en gros à peu près 5
milliards de tonnes équivalent pétrole
de d'énergie c'est-à-dire entre entre 4
et 5
c'est à dire un gros 40% de l'énergie
primaire
donc c'est clair que d'une mars
vous vous dites là il ya quelque chose à
gratter mais j'insiste c'est
essentiellement dû à la production
électrique et la production électrique
comme je vous l'avais dit dans un conte
précédent est aujourd'hui
essentiellement faite avec des
combustibles fossiles et donc là vous
avez essentiellement la perte due au
fait que c'est une machine de carnot et
vous pouvez juste rien y faire vous
pouvez un peu monter la température de
la source chaude
voilà mais vous pouvez pas faire grand
chose de plus
alors voila voila je sais pas si je
voulais montrer en fait sa suspension
voilà où revoilà donc la décomposition
de la production électrique dans le
monde
est ce que vous voyez c'est que
aujourd'hui l'essentiel et fossiles vous
avez ici les 300 ce fossile garder en
ordre de grandeur que pour faire un kilo
watt heure d'électricité au charbon on
émet un kilo de co2 un ordre de grandeur
qui n'est pas inutile de garder en tête
le gaz est aux alentours de 400 grammes
le pétrole plutôt aux alentours de 800
les deux grands modes décarbonés
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne
l'électricité c'est l'hydroélectricité
et le nucléaire est tout en haut là vous
avez les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables alors qu'ils se baladent
n'importe où entre 10 et 250 g de co2
selon que vous êtes avec une éolienne
dont l'électricité n'a pas besoin d'être
stockés ça c'est dit g ou avec un
panneau solaire dont l'électricité a
besoin d'être ce taux est stocké sur
batterie particulièrement performante et
à ce moment vous êtes plutôt à 250 donc
ça il ya une très grande très grande
plage de variation
ce que vous voyez ici et alors je
reviendrai un peu tout à l'heure mais
c'est que la quantité d'électricité
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui dans le monde
a considérablement augmenté par rapport
à il ya quelques dizaines d'années on
est à peu près à 25 mille milliards de
kilowattheures est ce que vous voyez
c'est que dans les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables en fait vous avez le vent
est là la géothermie on va dire biogaz
géothermie qui sont les deux modes
domiens pour aller un peu plus loin
c'est à dire regardez à quel niveau il
faut placer les économies d'énergie il
ya maintenant une petite règle de trois
que je vous propose
qui est connu sous le nom d'équations de
kaya alors c'est pas un anagramme de
yaka
vraiment japonais que ça fait de kaya et
il a un jour posé l'équation de la
baisse des émissions de co2 sous forme
d'une règle de trois alors monsieur
callas il dit on va commencer par dire
que les émissions mondiales de co2 sont
égale à elle-même ce que normalement
même après une soirée bien arrosée ou de
voiliers accepté sans trop discuter et
puis monsieur cai a dit je vais divisé
et multiplier à droite par un terme non
nul droit de faire ça qui est la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise dans le
monde et donc là je fais apparaître un
premier terme qui est la quantité
d'énergie
la quantité de co2 pardon libéré dans
l'atmosphère par unité d'énergie
disponible pour moi d'accord par unité
de machines en fonctionnement après je
continue et je vais multiplier et / la
production économique donc ici ce que je
fais apparaître sait combien j'ai eu
besoin de transformer l'environnement
je vous rappelle que l'énergie c'est la
transformation de l'environnement pour
disposer d'un dollar de valeur ajoutée
d'accord pour disposer de à dollars de
quelque chose qui est intéressant pour
moi à combien et à quelle hauteur
expédiant kilowattheure j'ai eu besoin
de transformer l'environnement et enfin
je finis ma règle de trois en
multipliant et en divisant par la
population mondiale est donc là je fais
apparaître la quantité de production
économique de services économiques dit
autrement par personne fois le nombre de
personnes et donc là ce que vous voyez
c'est que on peut dire que les émissions
mondiales de co2 ou de gaz à effet de
serre soit dit en passant sont le
produit de quatre termes qui sont la
population donc toutes choses égales par
ailleurs plus on est nombreux plus un
email la production économique
plus on produit par personne plus on
transforme plus on aimait la quantité
d'énergie utilisée par unité de
production économique plus j'utilise
d'énergie par unité de production
économique plus des émissions de co2
augmentent toutes choses égales par
ailleurs
et enfin la quantité de co2 par unité
d'énergie plus mon unité d'énergie et
riches en co2 et plus toute chose égale
par
eur j mais est ce que je vous ai montré
tout à leur dit que le terme de gauche
je le mets sous contrainte c'est dire
que je dis d'ici à ce que vous ayez mon
âge faut que ce soit divisée par 3 j'ai
rajouté en dessous que ça finira de
toute façon par arriver un jour au titre
de mon petit théorème de l'autre jour là
qui est que la quantité de combustible
fossile qu'on utilise sur terre pendant
vers 0 à + l'infini de toute façon mes
émissions de co2 tendre vers zéro à plus
infinie aussi donc de toutes façons
viendra un moment où dans l'histoire des
hommes
les émissions de co2 seront pour
toujours inférieure au tiers de la
valeur actuelle je suis sûr de ça j'ai
pas vous dire quand je suis sûr que ça
arrivera et maintenant on va essayer de
regarder
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire sur les
termes de droite vous êtes d'accord avec
moi que si on and on divise sa part 3 il
faut que je retrouve la division par
trois dans la combinatoire des termes de
droite c'est ça le grand charme d'une
égalité c'est que ça doit rester égal
des deux côtés de l'égalité alors une
première option est de dire je vais
diviser la population humaine par trois
en trente ans apporte des non pas très
sympathique donc en général il ya peu de
candidats mais je reviendrai à la fin je
peux déjà vous dire parce que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi que si ça doit arriver
de toute façon tout ce qui n'est pas
fait là là et là ce sera fait la voie
d'accord c'est juste de l'arithmétique 1
donc tout ce qui n'est pas fait là là et
là sera fait ici juste arithmétique
pour le moment la population on se dit
plutôt bon allez ça va encore augmenter
et on est parti pour être 9 à 10
milliards sur terre bon très bien alors
je 9 à 10 milliards par rapport à la
taille actuelle de la population ça fait
en gros une augmentation de 30%
donc ça se doit de diviser par trois et
ça j'ai commencé par x 1,3 du coup les
trois termes qui restent se doit les
diviser par 4 points d'accord oui en a
qu'un seul qui écoute non on est
d'accord alors la deuxième option
maintenant c'est à dire pas très bien je
vais diviser le pib par personne par
quatre dans les 30 ans qui viennent
d'autres manières de faire alors tous
les gens qui se préoccupent de
l'industrialisation du pays des caisses
de retraite de chez pas quoi sinon vous
pensez pas on pourra faire ça en fait il
faut que ça monte et alors là les
intérêts composés vous disent que si on
part sur l'idée que dans le monde parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est en ça que tout le
monde a en tête ont fait 2 % par an est
bien un excellent vous fait beaucoup
mieux que moi 1,02 à la puissance 32 et
ça vous donne une petite multiplication
par 2 à l'échelle des trente deux ans
qui viennent
donc ça j'ai dû comme je veux le diviser
par 3 et là je commence par x 1,3 et par
deux en fait le coin la combinatoire des
dossiers par 2,5
donc vous êtes d'accord que si sage le x
2,5 et ça je le diviser par trois le
produit de ces deux termes je dois / je
crois avoir entendu sept et demi je vous
rappelle que les règles de trois c'est
beaucoup plus utile dans la vie courante
que les intégrales triple un beaucoup
plus c'est avec ça que vous ferez pas
estompée par votre plombier et parlement
par le marchand de voitures alors que
les intégrales trick ne vous serviront à
rien dans les deux cas de figure je
viens d'évoquer
donc il faut que les deux termes qui
restent soit divisé par 7 et 10 on est
d'accord
et alors j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour
vous les deux termes qui reste c'est
votre job c'est votre job c'est le
boulot des ingénieurs faites-moi des
machines plus efficace et faites moi une
énergie plus décarbonée allez-y au
boulodrome de feignants parce qu'on va
quand même pas faire baisser le pib est
sans péché
d'avoir une population qui croît donc
faites votre job voilà alors c'est un
peu plus compliqué que ça parce que si
je demande aux gens qui vous ont
précédés d'envoyer leur cv en disant qu
est ce que vous avez fait sur ces deux
termes là je vais revenir un peu plus
tard mais vous voyez sur l'efficacité
énergétique de l'économie
en gros on a été capable de gagner 30%
en un peu plus de 50 ans et même si je
regarde sur les 20 dernières années
eh bien on est plutôt à -10%
c'est à dire qu'on gagne péniblement un
demi point d'efficacité énergétique par
an actuellement sur les 20 dernières
années
nonobstant l'explosion du smart haïti
qui doit rendre tous marque dans tous
les sens
smart taxi volant smartcity smart
ingénieur des mines ce marc machin va
smart tous maîtres de l'efficacité dans
tous les sens mais justement ça marche
pas très bien puisque depuis qu'on m'a
dit marc machin dans tous les sens
l'efficacité a plutôt tendance à
s'améliorer moins vite que plus vite un
macroscopiquement et donc si je dis ça
je dois le diviser par sept et demi ça
je gagne péniblement 30% là dessus vous
êtes d'accord que j'ai encore un gros
facteur 5 à trouver là dessus
malheureusement c'est pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé sur les 50 dernières années
on a gagné on go 10% sur ce terme là
sur les 50 dernières années et depuis le
boom née nerfs on gagne rien là aussi
c'est quand même dommage
en fait le boom et nrj revient une fois
de plus c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
c'est à dire que dans le même temps que
les horaires augmentent le charbon et le
gaz continuent d'augmenter
si fait que le contenu carbone moyen de
l'énergie incrémentale et bien il est
plutôt plus fort que le contenu carbone
moyen de l'énergie qui était déjà
employé le boom des nerfs des 15
dernières années est allée de pair avec
le boom du charbon ce que j'expliquais
au moment du premier cours donc on a
fait 10 % alors je le répète à partir du
moment où
soit la géologie régional ou mondial
soit n'importe quelle contrainte
les gens paniquent j'en sais rien fait
que ce terme blanc devient effectivement
rapidement des croissants tout ce qui
n'est pas pris là et là le sera là et là
c'est juste des maths c'est jude est
donc je vais vous le dire autrement les
économies d'énergie celles là sont
évidemment les meilleurs mais il y en a
une partie qu'on va devoir prendre là
c'est à dire la sobriété et où la
pauvreté est idéalement la sobriété
parce que à tout prendre c'est peut-être
mieux d'avoir un pib en baisse
plutôt que de se faire la guerre de
mourir de maladies ou mourir de faim
mais cette équation elle est là pour
rappeler que l'arithmétique
malheureusement nous dit qu' il n'y aura
pas de voix avec le problème repousser
éternellement à plus tard
alors voilà maintenant quelques zooms
pour montrer qu'en plus le problème se
complique encore donc ici vous avez
l'efficacité énergétique de l'économie
pour le monde dans son ensemble voyez ça
baisse mais il ya des pays dans lequel
ça se dégrade pris avec le temps
ici vous avez la turquie par exemple eh
bien vous voyez en ce qui concerne la
turquie
aujourd'hui il faut plus d'énergie pour
faire un dollar de valeur ajoutée qu'il
n'en fallait il ya 50 ans d'accord donc
ils n'ont pas amélioré leur économie ils
ont dégradé l'efficacité énergétique de
leurs économies
ici vous avez un alors je suis désolé
j'ai pris la courbe anvers mais ça a dit
exactement la même chose en ce qui
concerne le brésil vous avez combien
vous faites de dollars de valeur ajoutée
par kilowatts heure d'énergie donc s'est
présenté dans l'autre sens donc là pour
le coup quand ça baisse c'est que
l'énergie les connaît
et de moins en moins efficace vous fait
de moins en moins de dollars de valeur
ajoutée avec la même quantité de
kilowattheures et voyez que le brésil
c'est pareil est un pays où l'économie
est moins efficace aujourd'hui qu'elle
ne l'était il ya 50 ans là vous avez un
voisin immédiat qui s'appelle l'espagne
et bien vous voyez l'espagne à une
économie qui aujourd'hui n'est pas plus
efficace qu'elle ne l'était il ya 50 ans
c'est devenu un peu plus efficace ça
s'est dégradé
c'est devenu un peu plus efficace 0
dégradé enfin d'accord donc se dire
qu'avec le temps tout devient toujours
plus efficace malheureusement c'est pas
aussi simple que ça je vous ai montré
que dans le monde
c'était pas vrai l'efficacité s'était
améliorée plus vite
jusqu'en 2002 après de ville et vous
avez des pays dans lesquels depuis qu'on
regarde ce genre de statistiques
et bien vous pouvez avoir la situation
qui va dans le mauvais sens et non pas
dans le bon sens en ce qui concerne
l'efficacité carbone de l'énergie donc
je le redis c'est combien de grammes de
co2 vous devez mettre dans l'atmosphère
quand vous utilisez un kilowattheures
d'énergie primaire il s'agit pas de
l'électricité là il s'agit bien
d'énergie de primaire et bien ce que
vous voyez c'est que ça s'améliorait
lentement jusqu'au début des années 2000
et depuis le début des années 2000
angot ça s'est un peu dégradé un peu
amélioré ses flat
donc ça c'est très contre-intuitif par
rapport au discours qu'on entend partout
qui est encore une fois que les énergies
renouvelables sont en train de se
développer partout et donc la logique
devrait être que l'énergie se d'écart
bonnement est ce que vous voyez là c'est
que c'est pas du tout le cas ici vous
avez eu comme facteur de décarbonation
de l'énergie qu'on utilise deux choses
vous avez eu le passage pour partie la
montée en puissance du gaz qui est la
moins carboné des énergies fossiles
donc si vous avez le gaz qui se
développe du coup la valeur moyenne du
co2 mis dans la dans l'atmosphère pour
un kilowattheures d'énergie primaire a
tendance à baisser un peu et le deuxième
facteur explicatif
c'est le développement de
hydro électricité enfin surtout au début
et du nucléaire mais il n'ya pas que ça
il ya aussi le fait que le gaz et
augmenter en là vous avez le retour du
charbon j'ai envie de dire et là
effectivement le développement des
réseaux nerfs enfin vous voyez que tout
ça c'est des oscillations autour d'une
valeur qui ne bouge pas dans les grands
ordres de grandeur si vous avez des pays
dans lesquels ces très stable oui par
exemple un très très stable depuis des
dizaines d'années si on regarde ce
paramètre sur une série beaucoup plus
longue
là en l'occurrence un siècle et demi
c'est un petit calcul que j'ai fait à
partir des séries longues d'énergie que
je vous ai montré au premier cours
j'ai regardé comment avez évolué le
contenu carbone de l'énergie utilisée
par les hommes depuis un siècle et demi
alors là en l'occurence j'ai compté la
biomasse pour zéro ce qui est un peu
discutable parce qu'une partie de la
biomasse qu'on a utilisé et et de la
déforestation
mais bon ceci ceux ci visent à part ce
que vous voyez c'est que la révolution
industrielle a précisément consisté à
carbonne et l'énergie c'est ça que ça va
consister à faire c'est à mettre plus de
combustibles fossiles dans ce monde
utilisaient me rappelle encore une fois
qu'il ya deux ou trois siècles on était
100% vénère et depuis les chocs
pétroliers partant depuis le début du
20e siècle
ce que vous voyez c'est que en gros avec
des oscillations cette valeur est resté
à peu près constante
donc il ya une forme de grandes
difficultés à sortir de l'énergie
fossile dans la civilisation
industrielle dans laquelle nous sommes
très très difficile d'en sortir
c'est ce que vous montre le cette série
alors ça n'empêche pas les discours sur
la décarbonation de l'économie de
prendre place conjuguée à un discours
sur la croissance du pib ce qui veut
dire comme le pib c'est une
transformation on a besoin de plus
d'énergie
donc on a besoin de beaucoup plus
d'énergie avec beaucoup moins d'énergie
fossile donc en gros pour conjuguer les
deux discours qui sont à la fois
l'économie doit continuer à croître
et la quantité d'énergie fossile bois
rapidement décroître ça veut dire qu'on
devrait passer d'une évolution
historique de l'utilisation de l'énergie
qui est cette courbe que je vous ai déjà
montré à une évolution future
d'ici à ce que vous ayez mon âge je
répète qui ressemble à ça c'est à dire
que en bas les combustibles fossiles se
mettent à décroître de 3 4% par an alors
ça physiquement ça pose pas de problème
que ça pose des problèmes socio
économiques tant qu'on veut mais ça ne
pose aucun problème physique
c'est-à-dire de diminuer très fortement
la quantité de combustible
c'est physiquement possible ça tu es
moins sûr il faudrait que dans le même
temps les énergies décarbonées
croissance de 7% par an tous les ans
dans les 32 ans qui viennent sachant
qu'une bonne partie on va y venir plus
tard de ces énergies décarbonées reste
dépendante des énergies fossiles à un
moment ou à un autre de la chaîne alors
plus ou moins fortement
évidemment mais
quand même oui
on verra ça pendant cours sur le
nucléaire
alors maintenant je vais vous proposer
une alternative à kayar que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure qui est plus du
tout la même
alors je ne tue personne donc on a
toujours la population qui se prend 20 à
30% alors je ne tue personne mais on
essaye de faire en sorte que la
population croise quand même un peu
moins vite alors c'est quelque chose qui
est tout à fait faisable pour ça il faut
développer il faut que l'aide au
développement des pays riches soit
vraiment de l'aide au développement et
pas de l'aide en général aussi
d'affaires des entreprises des pays
occidentaux est ok donc pour faire des
routes et des ponts est l'un des trucs
les pays occidentaux peuvent faire
d'utile à ce moment c'est ce qui est
l'éducation des femmes le planning
familial et les systèmes de retraite qui
sont trois mesures dont on sait que ça a
un impact à la baisse sur la natalité
ont lieu de faire plus 30 je te cuisse
va là je dis allez hop on est content
comme on est avec le pib mondial tel
qu'il est donc l'arrêta mais comme je
suis un peu communiste et que je
considère que l'indien il a le même
droit au pib annuel que le français
évidemment le pib par personne en france
je divise par trois régimes communistes
je mets le paquet sur les économies
d'énergie au sens efficacité parce que
la sobriété j'ai déjà pris ma part ici
et je mets le paquet sur la
décarbonation de l'énergie donc
effectivement je construis à tire
larigot des barrages des centrales
nucléaires des éoliennes des panneaux
solaires tout ce qui me tombe sous la
main et la capture et séquestration du
co2 et à ce moment j'arrive à peu près à
tenir la division par trois sur le terme
de gauche
donc vous avez une petite idée de ce que
signifient les objectifs du
développement durable vu avec cette
règle de trois je vous rappelle soit dit
en passant que la pauvreté est un
indicateur relatif la pauvreté
c'est moins que x % du revenu médian
donc la pauvreté c'est la part d'une
distribution qui se trouve à gauche en
dessous d'une fraction du revenu médian
j'ai deux ou trois manières différentes
de supprimer la pauvreté la première
manière que j'ai c'est de concentrer la
totalité de faire un d'irak
donc tout le monde gagne la même chose à
ce moment je suis sûr que j'ai pas de
pauvreté puisque j'ai personnes à -2 et
on va dire 50% du revenu médian
d'accord il a mis en valeur absolue
toujours la même chose mais tous les
autres jeux baisse leurs revenus
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que ça fait
sa pauvreté on est d'accord
mathématiquement donc une deuxième
manière donc là ce que je vous présente
là c'est la seule manière que je
connaisse arithmétique qui résolvent à
la fois le problème du climat et le
problème de la pauvreté cje appauvri des
riches
c'est la seule manière qui fonctionne si
j'enrichis les pauvres ça marche pas
parce qu'à ce moment je commente la
production et donc augmente les
émissions de co2 donc j'insiste sur le
fait que la seule manière de coché
toutes les cases des objectifs du
développement durable ces dames
arithmétiquement je peux rentrer à vous
dire que c'est ça qu'il faut faire je
suis juste en train de vous dire
arithmétiquement le seul truc qui marche
si vous prenez ça en résolution de
problèmes
c'est d'abord est riche
si on veut se passer
alors voilà donc ça c'était pour
l'efficacité jaugeurs est vrai après sur
des exemples concrets
la deuxième chose donc il faut faire
c'est utiliser moins de combustibles
fossiles
si on veut utiliser moins de
combustibles fossiles
il faut notamment demandé aux gens qui
détiennent aujourd'hui les réserves de
combustibles fossiles de bien vouloir
les laisser sous terre d'accord ne pas
accorder de permis d'exploration de
permis d'exploitation etc
alors ici je vous reprocher tant
graphique que je vous avais déjà projeté
et qui vous donne la hiérarchie des
réserves en combustibles fossiles par
pays en ayant discriminer charbon
pétrole et gaz
je vous rappelle à nouveau que les
premiers détenteurs de réserves faute de
réserves liquides ont le venezuela c'est
un peu particulier parce que ce qu'il a
dans son sous sol c'est pas sûr qu'ils
en sortent tout ça même s'il le voulait
l'arabie saoudite est très en dessous de
la totalité des réserves de charbon du
pays de monsieur 30
et maintenant je vais vous montrer tous
les pays qu'ils étaient d'accord en 1997
pour prendre un engagement de limitation
de leurs propres émissions ce qui vous
donne quelques par le consentement à
agir au nom du climat des pays en
question
et donc c'est un pré requis pour le
consentement a laissé sous terre les
réserves fossiles dont il dispose
alors voilà dans toutes ces pays-là
trois pays qui ont soit ratifiée
tardivement soit carrément laissé tomber
leur ratification donc le canada est
sorti la russie a ratifié extrêmement
tardivement et les états unis ont fini
par sortir ils n'ont jamais ratifié
et tous ces pays là à cette époque là
ils n'ont jamais pris d'engagement
d'accord donc en gros ce que vous voyez
sur ce graphique c'est que les gens qui
sont d'accord pour agir au nom du climat
c'est essentiellement les gens comparent
de réserve chez eux
c'est essentiellement la ces gens là ils
sont d'accord pour agir au nom du climat
et je vous rappelle également quelque
chose de très important que vous avez
dit la dernière fois
enfin une dernière fois qui est que le
charbon dont vous voyez qu'il représente
l'essentiel des réserves extractible
restante est une énergie essentiellement
domestique donc le charbon il s'extrait
chez soi et une s'utilise chez soi donc
tant que les pays sont souverains ceux
qui ont du charbon il ne dépend que
d'eux mêmes d'extraire leur charbon et
d'utiliser leur charbon pour faire de
l'électricité
ça ne dépend que d'eux corps il est
assez peu probable que le vietnam ou la
thaïlande ou le brésil où l'autriche
déboule en chine en disant vous
n'utilisez pas votre charbon assez peu
probable ou en australie
donc le donc ces pays là il voit
l'utilisateur charbon il utilise donc il
faut les convaincre de pas l'utiliser ce
qui évidemment pas très simple un autre
élément dont il faut tenir compte tout
ça prépare encore une fois la discussion
sur les mesures techniques c'est que
l'essentiel des émetteurs donc
l'essentiel des pays qui ont pris des
engagements c'est ce qu'ont pas les
réserves et par ailleurs l'essentiel des
émetteurs sont des pays dans lesquels
vous avez actuellement un régime dit
démocratique
vous voyez que sur ce camembert qui
représente l'ensemble des régions du
monde à part quelques exceptions alors
la plus notable
évidemment et la chine et une bonne
partie des pays du moyen-orient
mais sinon l'essentiel des autres pays
sont des démocraties
alors on peut dire ce qu'on veut
qu'elles sont pas parfaites et c'est la
notion de démocratie parfaite pour moi
est quelque chose qui reste un monde est
là parce qu'il n'ya pas de définition
normative de ce que c'est qu'une
démocratie parfaite
moi j'ai envie de dire c'est une
démocratie à partir du moment où les
gens votent
voilà c'est ça ma définition qu'après on
explique que le vote est truqué mal
organes
il est encore et c'est très bien reste à
savoir ce que serait un vote pas truqué
mais où un vote parfait en général tout
la critique la meilleure que je
connaisse exactement la meilleure
manière de traduire
ceci n'est pas démocratique par exemple
dans un débat un débat non démocratiques
en général est un débat qui conclut à
autre chose que mon opinion meilleure
définition que je connaisse donc voilà
donc là on a affaire à des démocraties
c'est à dire des endroits où on vote est
une démocratie c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut que vous ayez bien à l'esprit
j'espère que vous êtes tous aller voter
aux européennes
c'est un système qui n'est pas un
système auquel vous êtes habitués dans
votre vie de tous les jours dans votre
vie de tous les jours vous êtes habitué
à être dans une institution dans
laquelle il y a des règles avec une
autorité qui est capable dé dicter les
règles des gens derrière qui doivent
respecter les règles et des sanctions en
cas de non-respect des règles donc je
prends l'école des mines où vous vous
trouvez l'école des mines à des règles
par exemple si vous ne passez pas un
examen vous avez zéro et une deuxième
règle c'est que si vous avez trop de
zéro vous n'avez pas votre diplôme et
comme vous êtes pas rentrer ici pour en
ressortir sans diplôme
eh bien vous faites les efforts minimum
qu'il faut pour avoir votre diplôme
ce qui fait que tous ceux qui ont le
plaisir d'avoir un rattrapage courons
derrière en disant est ce que vous
voulez bien le corriger parce que sinon
la direction des études me fais des gens
qui déambulent donc c'est quelque chose
qui a encore une fois une hiérarchie un
vrai chef qui décide et en pouvoir de
sanction alors tous on a tendance à
penser qu'un système politique en
démocratie ça fonctionne de la même
manière vous avez un vrai chef
il décide et ensuite on s'exécute alors
en fait pas du tout dans les livres que
je ne vaux saurait trop vous conseiller
de lire il ya un livre s'appelle de la
démocratie en amérique
écrit par un génie qui s'appelle alexis
de tocqueville il ya maintenant
quasiment de siècle dans lequel il
décortique alors je
je vous passe le premier tome parce que
le premier tome il décortique par le
menu les pouvoirs du juge en amérique
passionnant par contre le deuxième est
absolument fabuleux parce qu'il fait une
lecture sociologique extrêmement fine de
la façon dont une démocratie poussera
les hommes à se comporter et il n'y a
pas une virgule a changé par rapport à
ce qu'on peut observer aujourd'hui quand
une démocratie c'est un système
remontant ou plus exactement une
pyramide inversée c'est à dire que lui
il a en bas en fait il est chargé
d'écouté et d'arbitrer entre tous les
gens qui vont vous dire voilà ce qu'il
faut faire
et alors évidemment ils sont pas tous
d'accord entre eux et tous ils votent
c'est à dire que tous ils décident s'ils
lui en bas là il sera chef op h f
exactement s'il sera exécuteurs
testamentaires ou pas donc une
démocratie contrairement à une
entreprise une institution universitaire
comme celle dans laquelle vous êtes ou
par courriel d'administration c'est pas
un endroit où le chef est un vrai chef
qui impose sa volonté à une population
qui n'en voudrait pas le chef est un
faux chefs qui se fait élire donc qui a
besoin d'être dans un rapport de
séduction permanent avec les gens qui
votent et qui va en fonction de ce qui
est entre guillemets dans l'air du temps
prendre des positions qui peuvent
parfaitement changé du tout au tout en
l'espace de 24 heures
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont en
mémoire l'histoire de la taxe carbone
parce que c'est un tout petit peu lié à
ce que je vais vous raconter aujourd'hui
vous vous rappelez peut-être que au
moment de la mise en place de la taxe
carbone nous sommes passés
successivement en l'espace d'une semaine
deux
au moment de la houle et gilet jaune ont
commencé à aboyer contre le prix de
l'essence
à juste titre pour partie je reviendrai
après et bien ils sont passés de nous
seront inflexibles sur la taxe carbone
on va remettre à plus tard et à on
abandonne tout ça en l'espace d'une
semaine
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui est
emblématique du fonctionnement dans une
démocratie
je le redis l'élu est au service de ses
électeurs au moins autant qu ils leur
demandent de s'exécuter
tu lis bien loin alors notre ami tobin
qui avait passé la démocratie à la loupe
nous a dit il ya maintenant deux siècles
à cause de la façon dont le système est
construit par exemple on considère que
tout le monde est égal sur la ligne de
départ
donc si les gens sont pas égaux sur la
ligne d'arrivée c'est qu'il ya une
injustice quelque part d'accord c'est ya
eu une injustice qui part puisque l'on
était tous au même niveau sur la ligne
de départ
un machin il a gagné plus que moi c'est
dégueulasse il habite une plus belle
maison c'est dégueulasse il est un peu
grosse voiture dégage tout ça c'est
parce que encore une fois comme on était
sur la ligne de départ au même moment et
avec les mêmes droits mardi à l'arrivée
on doit être pareil donc ce que
tocqueville 10 et la démocratie et
rendra les gens rouspéteur voilà rendra
les gens consumériste j'ai le droit
j'ai le droit donc je le prends rendra
les gens court termiste rendra les gens
individualiste voilà tout ça c'était
qu'il ya exactement deux siècles tanguy
les cris de honte la démocratie poussera
à la consommation de masse la
consommation masse pouce aux changements
climatiques
ah merde comment je fais pour garder la
démocratie sans consommation de masse
pas simple pige à partir du moment où
vous avez le droit
comment est ce qu'on fait pour vous
enlever le droit
tocqueville avait également dit que en
démocratie il y aura un truc qui sera un
lieu de pouvoir absolument majeur c'est
les médias alors là dedans vous pouvez
les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
et que soit dit en passant ça sera le
seul pouvoir sans rentrer pouvoir en
démocratie que la démocratie alors c'est
une variante de court termiste ce qui
fera le buzz c'est les petits machins
superficiel et effectivement le rouge à
l'aide de kim kardashian fait plus de
vues sur youtube qu'une conférence
philosophique sur où allons nous dans
les 50 ans qui viennent
et du coup du coup ce que tocqueville
dit c'est que la démocratie recèle en
elle même sa propre fragilité qui est
d'être incapable de gérer correctement
les grands dangers de long terme et
alors évidemment comme vous êtes tous
des gens qui ont été formés à la logique
élémentaire si la démocratie n'est pas
capable d'accoucher du système qui
permet de gérer le problème
la solution involontaire au problème se
passera de la démocratie c'est là qu'ont
proposé
oui
à l'époque la seule alternative que
tocqueville connaissais c'était la
monarchie qui est une dictature
patrimoniale j'ai envie de dire enfin de
père en fils ou de mère en fils
et effectivement tocqueville disait par
exemple en monarchie
les gens sont fatalistes donc les gens
se contentent de ce qu'ils ont et il
accepte un système immuable et confère
ce que je vous avais dit à un moment sur
quand je vous avait reconstitué dans le
premier cours je crois le pib sur deux
siècles dans sur deux millénaires par
dont je vous avais dit tant qu'il y
avait pas de croissance il n'y avait pas
de démocratie parce que j'ai fait une
petite blague en disant ce n'est pas la
peine de la promettre mais de fait
c'était pas la peine de la promesse
n'est pas d'élection parce qu'il ait pas
de démocratie est ce que l'histoire nous
enseigne c'est que des systèmes sachant
gérer la fin adaptée à un contexte
stable qu'il émerge plus exactement
quand le contexte est stable sont des
systèmes qui sont significativement plus
coercitif que la démocratie parce qu'en
démocratie dès que vous promettez plus
alain vous ne savez pas promettre - à
l'autre or dans un monde stable c'est ce
que vous devez faire c'est très
difficile d'enlever en démocratie vous
voyez bien je vais vous enlever un peu
de votre temps de retraite pour 25 ans
donc je dis pas que c'est bien ou mal je
me dis juste de fait quand vous regardez
c'est tout ce qui consiste à enlever et
quelque chose qui est extrêmement lent
et c'est pour ça que les systèmes dans
lesquels on a besoin d'enlever
rapidement son général pas des
démocraties
une entreprise c'est un système dans
lequel vous avez besoin d'enlever
rapidement un moment éventuellement vous
faites deux plus mauvaises affaires vous
avez besoin malheureusement de licenciés
du monde
eh bien vous dit pas on va faire des
élections pour savoir qui ont licencié
non prenez une décision et vous le
faites je dis pas encore une fois que
c'est bien ou c'est mal j'observe
simplement que le système est adapté à
une prise de décision plus rapide parce
que la décision plus rapide est
nécessaire quand vous vous avez affaire
à quand vous êtes devant la nécessité
d'en lever quelque chose à court terme
et c'est pareil sur un bateau vous avez
un capitaine
il fait pas un référendum tous les
quatre matins pour savoir si on a fallu
la voile on envoie la voile on va à
gauche on va à droite seul maître à bord
après dieu vous rappeler de cette
formule donc quand vous êtes dans un
système dans lequel vous avez
éventuellement besoin d'enlever quelque
chose ou de prendre une mesure
contraignante à court terme
l'histoire nous montre que c'est jamais
système démocratique donc là ce que je
suis en train de vous dire c'est pas
juste pour le plaisir de philosopher je
suis en train de dire on a une vraie
question dont à mon avis on n'est pas du
tout assez conscient dans le débat
public qui est la démocratie a du mal à
faire accoucher d'économie parce que les
économistes et des contraintes
c'est là que voulait en venir sauf que
si on ne sait pas gérer de nous mêmes la
contrainte
l'histoire nous enseigne que au moment
où le contexte est ce qui nous pousse à
la contrainte à ce moment pas
complètement sûr que ce système là
perdure d'une façon longue oui
alors ça dépend de l'entreprise ça
dépend de son histoire c'est beaucoup
c'est très vrai dans les sociétés
financiarisé quand vous êtes cotées en
bourse
c'est encore plus vrai quand vous avez
un patron lardé de stock options qui ne
pensent que ce partir dans les cinq ans
qui viennent en dix ans après je suis
tranquille
c'est beaucoup moins vrai dans les
petites sociétés patrimoniale par
exemple si vous prenez un vigneron
j'ai aussi une entreprise si vous avez
des copains à l'agro fils de champenois
ou filles de champenois et bien c'est
des gens qui peuvent très bien raisonner
à 20-30 ans sans aucun problème donc ça
dépend vraiment de la nature de
l'entreprise
vous avez plein plein d'entreprises
patrimoniales dans lesquelles les
exigences de rendement sur capitaux et
les horizons de temps ont rien à voir
avec effectivement les grandes sociétés
cotées en bourse ou là les horizons de
temps sont venus très court ce qui est
un vrai problème
je fais partie des gens qui à titre
personnel considère qu'on devrait
appuyer fortement sur la [ __ ] de frein
de ce côté là on devrait supprimer les
comptes trimestriels supprimer la
cotation en continu enfin tous ces trucs
là ferait énormément de bien
notamment à la résolution des problèmes
de long terme
voilà je peux me faire des copains dans
les cabinets d'audit il dit ça ça comme
je travaille pas je m'en fiche mais
c'est mais très clairement on aurait
besoin de freiner fortement le système
et c'est très clair dernier point en ce
qui concerne la démocratie
le bulletin de vote ne dépend pas de vos
connaissances préalables
je ne dis pas encore une fois que c'est
bien ou c'est mal ça fait partie du
cahier des charges
donc on vous de ronfler va passer un
test de connaissance avant de vous
demander votre avis sur le programme
d'un candidat donc un candidat qui dit
je vais greffer un troisième bras à
chacun on vous dont on fait pas passer
un test de connaissances pour savoir si
c'est faisable ou pas faisable et s'il
faut qu'ils embauchent le roi alexandre
avant de voter pour lui vous votez avec
ce que vous savez et donc comme l'avait
dit tocqueville il ya quelque chose
d'absolument centrale en démocratie qui
s'appelle les médias alors à nouveau je
vous propose quelques petits calculs
d'ordre de grandeur
parce que tu es bien ce que je vais vous
dire aussi vous allez toute votre vie
vivre dans des mondes à l'information
imparfaite
encore une fois que vous allez sortir
d'ici vous vivrez dans un monde à
l'information un pare-feu l'univers
professionnel personnel dans lequel vous
évoluerez vous demandera de discuter
avec des gens qui ne seront jamais sur
la même base de connaissances que vous
étes ou lui ou elle
ou vous aura de toute façon une partie
des connaissances manquantes pour faire
le tour du problème dont vous êtes en
train de discuter
alors regardez les ordres de grandeur à
partir du moment enfin le l'information
ce qu'on appelle à la source donc en
gros vous allez venir en cours ce dont
je vous remercie et
consciencieusement et religieusement
écouté pendant 24 heures ce qui est
beaucoup plus que ce que sont la majeure
partie des gens dans ce pays pour sa
culture et à ce problème là ça va
concerner une population de quelques
dizaines à quelques centaines de
milliers de personnes dans le pays
si je regarde la population que moi je
vais toucher directement ma vie durant
ça va se balader aux alentours de 50 à
100 mille personnes et puis en face de
ça vous vous appelez le présentateur
vous appelez au boulot pardon alors
hanouna il fait pas d'informations enfin
ou en tout cas pas les mêmes je pensais
plutôt à gilles bouleau
ou au beau gosse de france 2 a oublié le
nom à l'instant à ce moment vous allez
avoir quelques millions de personne en
face de vous tous les soirs
donc vous voyez qu'on n'est pas du tout
sur le même ordre de grandeur est en
fait en démocratie un des jets envie de
dire un des sujets centraux quand on
pense que l'expertisé est importante
dans le débat public s'est assurée le
chemin qui va de en haut à gauche a en
bas à droite c'est à dire comment est ce
que je fais pour que les gens qui sont
des relais d'information essaye de
relayer pour en revenir à ce que j'avais
dit au moment de l'énergie ce qui est
important et non pas ce qui est nouveau
je peux vous assurer que c'est pas
gagner tous les jours voilà donc il faut
faire attention au fait que le ce qu'il
ya dans le journal n'est pas
nécessairement représentatif je le
répète ce qui est important dans le
monde et que le
la manière dont la population va réagir
un problème donné
ce fait beaucoup plus au regard de ce
qu'il ya dans le journal ou qui circule
sur les réseaux sociaux avec beaucoup
d'audience c'est pareil que au regard
des faits et s'il ya une discordance
entre les deux c'est la représentation
médiatique des faits qui gagne c'est pas
les faits alors évidemment c'est un
exercice qui est compliqué si je prends
la vulgarisation de ce qu'on sait sur le
changement climatique la totalité de ce
qui a été publié dans les revues
scientifiques sur quelque chose qui a de
près ou de loin un rapport avec le
changement climatique induit par les
hommes c'est des centaines de milliers
de pages de littérature scientifique
quand j'en fais un rapport du giec 2000
pages que probablement face il ya plus
de plus d une fois les doigts de la main
de d'élèves dans cette salle qui lisent
une fraction significative du rapport du
giec s'asseoir au maximum eh bien j'ai
déjà
opéré un taux de compression de quelques
centaines voyez entre toute la matière
disponible et un rapport de 2000 pages
si je passe au résumé pour décideurs
qu'une toute petite partie des décideurs
vont lire j'ai pas si vous avez vu il ya
une vidéo qui tourne sur youtube là où
il ya un étudiant belge qui interpellent
des politiques en belgique celle au
mieux et qui demande aux députés je
pense que les députés qui sont là qui
d'entre vous a lu le dernier résumé pour
décideurs du rapport à 1.5 du giec
oui entre 0 et une main qui se lève 3
oui enfin il ya une question de
traduction
normalement ils savent tous lire
l'anglais ou à peu près surtout si c'est
ou bien ils sont français et ils peuvent
lire en français ou bien ils sont
flamands et ils parlent tous anglais
presque donc de toute façon il ya un
vrai même en france à vous poser la même
question aux députés français vous
auriez 3 mathijsen donc et pourtant vous
êtes déjà passé vous avez rajouté un
taux de compression de 50 par rapport à
l'information disponible et quand vous
en faites un article dans le journal
en gros vous essayez de faire passer des
centaines d'heures de cours en une demi
seconde
vous avez aussi un énorme sujets liés au
fait que une information courte est une
information incomplète par construction
bon après pour la petite histoire je
rappelle également qu'un média c'est une
entreprise humaine comme les autres
comme les autres donc il ya ni plus ni
moins de rigueur dans un média qu'il n'y
en a ailleurs
donc quand vous lisez un article dans le
journal ou qu'on voyait un truc à la
télé vous savez pas pourquoi c'est ça
plutôt qu'autre chose
parce qu'il ya plein de trucs importants
dans le monde en permanence
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a interviewé
machin n'est pas bidule pourquoi est-ce
enfin est ce que dans ce qui a été dit
est ce qu'on a retenu correctement ce
qui a été dire je vais vous donner
quelques exemples quand ya un sujet ce
qu'on appelle un sujet c'est là c'est la
partie reportage dans un journal
télévisé savez dans un journal télévisé
n'importe quel sujet là pour le coup
c'est une minute trente à deux minutes
on parle sais pas quoi tiens pourquoi un
exemple récent des fraises bio sous
serre le truc c'est de minutes on va
interviewer une ou deux personnes
pendant ces deux minutes que vous allez
voir à l'écran 20 secondes
est ce que vous savez quel est le temps
d'interviews pour arriver à ces vingt
secondes en général une demi heure qui
décident de ce qui va y avoir dans les
20 secondes en question la personne
interviewée ça je peux vous le dire
c'est le journaliste qui interviewe la
journaliste qui interviewe qui décide de
ce qu'il va y avoir dans les 20 secondes
retenue donc la personne qui est
interviewé ne décide pas de ce qui lui
semble le plus important si on ne
retient que 20 secondes
les journalistes qui décide vous ne
savez pas ça et le présentateur ne vous
le dira pas il vous dira pas avant
chaque sujet et je vous rappelle que ce
qui apparaît à l'écran c'est le
journaliste qui a décidé on sait pas si
la personne interviewée considère que
c'est le plus important ou pas voilà
bien évidemment le système il est
asservi c'est à dire que
au moment où les gens rentrent en
fonction dans la presse eh bien ils ont
un avis et ça va évidemment conditionné
la façon dont ils ont traité les sujets
voilà donc la reine la raison pour
laquelle j'ai déjà dit plusieurs fois et
je le redis le journal n'est jamais une
chance opposable je maintiens le journal
mais j'avais une chance opposable donc
le journal ça vous sert à vous donner
une première information si vous voulez
mettre en avant cette information dans
n'importe quel processus dans lequel
vous avez besoin de quelque chose de
fiable et vérifiez vous êtes obligés
d'aller regardez par vous-mêmes derrière
d'aller retrouver l'information à la
source de vérifier que cette information
à la source elle-même est à peu près
crédible etc
vous ne pouvez jamais prendre je vais
vous le dire autrement un journal c'est
la fin d'un téléphone arabe
vous avez toujours téléphone arabe quand
vous étiez petits qui dans la salle a
déjà joué au téléphone arabe en étant
petit et n'a jamais vu la moindre
distorsion jamais jamais entre le début
de la chaîne et la fin voilà vous savez
pourquoi il faut pas croire un journal
c'est la fin d'un téléphone arabe dont
vous ne connaissez ni le nombre de
maillon intermédiaire ni la qualité de
transmission entre chaque maillon alors
pardon maintenant je vais revenir à tout
petit peu à la technique je vais revenir
un peu à la technique et donc avant de
parler des économies d'énergie je vais
parler des économies de co2 avec la
capture et séquestration du co2 qui est
l'une des manières de d'économiser de
l'énergie
donc là je vais encore une fois un peu
de un peu de segmentation ce graphique
est juste là pour rappeler que dans les
scénarisation qui sont faites sur la
part économies d'énergie versus
décarbonation de l'énergie dans les
scénarios aujourd'hui bas carbone
en gros c'est du 50 50
c'est à dire que dans les trajectoires
qui sont faites en disant on va tenir
les deux degrés en baissant les
émissions suffisamment en gros
là non pas tant c'est du 50 50 c'est
plutôt du 30 70 c'est 30% sur les
économies d'énergie l'efficacité
énergétique et ses 70 % sur
renouvelables ccs nucléaire en gros
c'est ça
les scénaristes ont fait alors une
première manière de décarbonés de
l'énergie c'est tout bêtement de rester
dans les énergies fossiles et de passer
du charbon au gaz
ici vous avez les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre alors en l'occurrence est
sont pas lancés aux deux autres sont en
carbone il faut que je pense à changer
ce graphique
donc en gros c'est quatre fois moins
mais peu importe c'est la hiérarchie qui
compte et vous voyez que quand on passe
du gaz au charbon on go on gagne un
facteur 2 en ce qui concerne les
émissions de combustion est donc partout
j'ai du charbon si je le remplace par du
gaz toutes choses égales par ailleurs je
baisse les émissions de co2 soit dit en
passant il ya un exemple emblématique de
pays qui à baisser ses émissions de co2
sur les dix dernières années en faisant
ça c'est
non pas l'allemagne non le pays qui est
pris comme l'emblème de lentilles
écologie dans le monde les états unis
les états unis ont très fortement
baisser la consommation de charbon dans
la production électrique qui l'ont
remplacé pour l'essentiel par du gaz et
c'est dû au fait que avec l'essor du gaz
de schiste aux états unis le prix du gaz
s'est effondré et du coup c'est devenu
plus rentable pour les électriciens
d'utiliser du gaz que du charbon
donc ils sont passés du charbon au gaz
et ça a contribué de manière
significative à la baisse des émissions
de co2 des états unis sur les dix
dernières années alors cela étant c'est
quelque chose qui est pendant et en
europe
c'est la raison également pour laquelle
les gaziers sont très allants sur l'idée
d'avoir un prix du co2 dont je vais vous
parler dans pas longtemps aussi parce
que si vous mettez un prix du co2 sur la
production électrique
ça pénalise d'électricité au charbon 1
kg de co2 par kilowattheure électrique
par rapport aux l'électricité au gaz 04
kg 400 grammes de co2 par kilowattheure
électrique et donc ça permet le
basculement du charbon vers le gaz
or les gaziers qui sont aussi des
pétroliers soit dit en passant il vente
du gaz mais ils vendent pas de charbon
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle le
patron de total
par exemple il ya un an et demi a fait
des grandes sorties dans la presse parce
que papa le produit plus de gaz pétrole
1 pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne le
savent pas donc le patron de total qui
vient de cette noble institution soit
dit en passant a fait des grandes
sorties dans la presse en disant il faut
un prix du co2 sur la production
électrique et il a même très justement
dit il faut que ce soit 30 euros la
tonne parce que 30 euros la tonne c'est
le prix qui fait basculer économiquement
du charbon vers le gaz
et c'est effectivement un moyen de
diviser les émissions de la production
électrique par trois si elle est faite
au charbon initialement ça reste
possible mais c'est un moyen de
décarbonés l'énergie alors c'est un
moyen sauf que pas
ans les grosses réserves de carbone sont
du côté des trucs très carbonée donc
c'est une marge de manoeuvre on peut
s'en servir c'est pas idiot
transitoirement transitoirement
définitivement évidemment non après on
peut séquestrer le co2 alors séquestrer
le co2 ça veut dire le capturer là où il
était mis une capture et séquestration
et ensuite le stocker dans un endroit
d'où il ne sortira plus ou du moins plus
avant que les hommes meurent et après il
fait ce qu'il veut alors dans les
endroits où on pense stocker ce co2 vous
en avez sous terre et sous l'océan sous
l'océan
l'idée c'est de le mettre sous forme
supercritiques et de le stocker de faire
des lacs de co2 au fond de l'océan alors
ça c'est quand même une idée que
maintenant beaucoup de gens abandonner
donc on oublie et par contre le
l'endroit enfin les endroits où on pense
en pouvoir en mettre sous terre c'est
soit des réservoirs d'hydrocarbures
épuisé un jeu fini soit des réservoirs
d'hydrocarbures épuisé donc il y avait
des roches poreuses dedans il y avait du
pétrole ou du gaz
il ya plus le pétrole ou le gaz dont il
ya de la place et à cette place
vous mettez du co2 alors c'est d'autant
plus intéressant de mettre du co2 là
dedans que en plus ça vous permet de
lessive et le pétrole qui reste donc aux
états unis vous avez depuis très
longtemps un réseau de gazoducs en
surface qui transporte du co2 qui sert
aux pétroliers le co2 est un produit
commercial aux états unis qui sert aux
pétroliers a lessivé les réservoirs de
pétrole pour faire mieux sortir le
pétrole d'accord évidemment vous stocker
du co2 mais dans le même temps vous fait
ressortir des combustibles fossiles qui
vont remettre du co2 mais par contre si
vous voulez juste mettre du co2 sans
faire ressortir du pétrole vous pouvez
dans les réservoirs d'hydrocarbures
épuisé vous pouvez également dans les
aquifères salins profonds sous terre est
en général de l'eau un peu partout et
donc quand vous avez un à qousseir
typiquement du sable imprégné d'eau et
bien c'est des endroits où vous pouvez
aussi injecté du co2
vous pouvez également injecter du co2
dans l'est dans les coulées basaltiques
voilà vous avez un certain nombre
d'endroits
vous pouvez mettre du co2 c'était pas la
question
pourquoi
bien sûr que si on peut le transformer
les réutiliser mais à ce moment il faut
casser l'énergie de liaison ses os et
dont vous avez besoin de plus d'énergie
pour casser l'énergie de liaison que ce
que vous allez récupérer derrière donc
vous pouvez refaire du carbone et de
l'oxygène
vous pouvez très bien mais pour ça il
vous faut de l'énergie
vous ne pouvez pas avoir une réaction
exothermique de transformation du co2 ça
c'est interdit la création du co2 est
exothermique une fois que vous avez créé
votre co2 il est stable
si alors il ya des gens qui proposent de
faire de la méta nation c'est-à-dire de
récupérer de carbone du co2 de mélanger
ça avec de l'hydrogène qu'on a par
ailleurs récupéré en d'électro lisant
etc alors les rendements de ce genre de
trucs sont de l'ordre de 20%
donc ils sont enfin je veux dire vous
êtes totalement par rapport à on en
parlera au moment des énergies
décarbonées mais l'idée de stocker
l'électricité de cette façon par rapport
au fait d'avoir des centrales nucléaires
pilotable c'est beaucoup moins cher
d'avoir du nucléaire pilotable si vous
n'êtes pas contre le nucléaire
en fait les dispositifs imaginés pour
faire ce genre de truc le sont par des
gens qui veulent pas de nucléaire en
général donc par exemple et gaziers qui
sont très contents parce que comme ça on
peut continuer à utiliser leur réseau ou
par exemple les gens qui sont férocement
contre le nucléaire et qui veulent tout
sauf du nucléaire mais si vous voulez
bien du nucléaire en fait le plus
pratique et de très loin
jusqu en plus c'est ce qui marche déjà
dont vous n'avez pas besoin de faire des
plans sur la comète
c'est d'utiliser du nucléaire et de
faire des systèmes pilotable ce qu'on
sait faire en france
je vais y revenir après en fait la
séquestration prend assez peu d'énergie
parce qu'une fois que le co2 est sous
forme supercritique le poids de la coloc
de co2 est à peu près suffisant pour
assurer l'injection du co2 dans la
couche la grosse consommation d'énergie
associées à ces races et la capture
parce que la capture elle est faite je
sais pas si j'ai un commentaire voilà ce
que ce que vous faites
en gros pour être sur ce que vous voulez
c'est injecté que le co2 si vous faites
de la combustion à l'air dans la fumée
vous avez plein d'azoté vous avais
aucune envie de mettre les autres sous
terre la sorte vous emmerde pas vous
n'avez jamais rien fait donc donc ce que
vous faites
à ce moment c'est que vous faites passer
les fumées d'abord les fumées vous devez
les épurer pour qu'il reste pas une
poussière pas de suivi etc
ensuite une fois que votre fumée et
épuré vous la fait passer sur un lit des
mines qui sont des molécules qui vont
vous absorbez de co2 de façon sélective
donc en gros votre fumée passe à travers
abada mines le co2 est absorbé la zot
s'en va et vous aller chauffer votre
bande am inn derrière pour décembre et
le co2 et à ce moment vous allez
désormais que du co2 vous récupérez du
co2 pur que vous allez comprimé
acheminés jusqu'au point d'injection est
injectée sous forme supercritique la
grosse consommation d'énergie du
processus s'est réchauffé les abîmes
c'est ça la grosse grosse consommation
d'énergie du processus l'injection elle
même
de mémoire c'est quelques pour cent de
l'énergie de départ par contre la
capture du co2 ces 20 à 30% d'énergie de
départ donc là vous avez une grosse
pénalité énergétique
à ce moment-là et
le problème c'est qu'à partir du moment
où vous avez le
vous avez 7 je sais pas si je reviendrai
après parce que j'ai c'est sur ses
suivants là ce que je fini par dire
c'est que donc il ya en capture et après
il faut acheminer jusqu'à un point
d'injection alors si vous avez une
centrale qui est construite sur un
bassin sédimentaire typiquement mer du
nord vous pouvez injecté pas loin de la
centrale
si votre centrale est construite sur un
massif granitique et bien un aquifères
salins vous allez avoir un peu de mal à
en trouver un et donc ça veut dire qu'il
va falloir transporter le co2 dans des
tuyaux et donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
un les construire de accepter ses
infrastructures en surface enfin voilà
vous avez un sujet qui est aussi un
sujet d'infrastructures de transport
donc ce que je vois là ce que je voulais
dire c'est que oui ah parce que c'est
parce que le alors le co2 il a cette
particularité thermodynamique il devient
super critique quand il est à haute
température hauteur
à haute pression et c'est un état
intermédiaire entre le gaz et le liquide
particularité thermodynamique qui là et
à ce moment soit dit en passant il est
très peu visqueux et il est dense comme
un fluide donc vous en injecter des plus
grande quantité que s'il était gazole
évidemment oui
c'est plus compliqué de mettre du bois
dans une roche de mettre un truc qui est
liquide faire rentrer du bois dans l'est
dans les réservoirs de pétrole a encore
une fois c'est la craie ou du grès ou du
sable
donc voyez faire entrer une bûche dans
un morceau de grèce quand même compliqué
c'est quand même pas pressé c'est plus
simple de faire entrer du liquide cela
étant blague à part du coup vous
comprenez aussi que ça rende pas si vide
que ça donc ça veut dire que pour
injecter des très très grandes quantités
de co2 dans le sol il faut multiplier un
peu comme des puits de gaz de schiste
aux états-unis sauf que sa valeur au
sens il faut multiplier les puits
d'injection parce que par puits
d'injection vous n'avez pas un débit
extrêmement élevé oui
bon
il
on
c est ma b au clsc ça est ce qui fait
fonctionner la centrale électrique lassé
de la biomasse voilà ça c'est juste
c'est une variante de ça mais avec de la
biomasse audio que ça fonctionne avec du
gaz ou du charbon
si vous faites fonctionner avec du gaz
et du charbon vous êtes en circuit fermé
ça sort de la save à la sarthe au delà
si vous faites fonctionner avec de la
biomasse vous êtes en circuit
d'injection ça vient de là ça va dans la
biomasse ça va là ça passe tout seul
d'accord donc le point de départ et le
point d'arrivée son golden sont pas les
mêmes pardon voilà oui donc le pour en
revenir à la question du rendement en
fait la grosse limitation de la capture
c'est la pénalité énergétique alors
imaginons vous ayez une centrale
électrique
aujourd'hui elle est dimensionnée pour
fournir une certaine quantité
d'électricité
vous appliquez de la capture et
séquestration
du coup 30% du charbon ou du gaz que
vous enfourner dans votre centrale sert
à autre chose du coup votre rendement
électrique baisse de 30% vous allez
prendre % d'électricité en moins à
l'arrivée
question comment est-ce que vous gérez
30% d'économie d'électricité imposé et
la vraie limitation de la capture et
séquestration elle est là elle n'est pas
dans le fait que il faut payer 60 euros
la tonne de co2 pour que ce soit
rentable pour l'électricien le vrai
sujet c'est que à laval vous avez moins
d'électricité
donc vous avez moins de machines qui
fonctionnent donc vous avez un problème
économique
il est là le vrai sujet alors vous
pouvez dire pourquoi c'est parfait on
renverse le problème et on augmente la
puissance de la centrale de 40% alors on
peut le faire
sauf que si c'est une centrale à charbon
il faut augmenter la taille du bailleur
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure de 40%
il faut augmenter le convoyeur qui va
jusqu'à la centrale de 40% ils font
augmenter les brûleurs faut augmenter la
capacité des brûlures de 40%
il faut augmenter l'évacuation des
cendres de 40% et
la rue centrale tout à l'heure lc 10
mille tonnes 60 par jour et c est donc
en fait vous avez des gros problèmes
logistiques sur votre centrale que vous
ne savez pas résoudre à bref délai donc
la limitation de la capture et
séquestration sur la production
électrique
c'est pas que ça coûte cher en fait que
ça coûte cher c'est pas le problème le
problème c'est que vous avez une perte
physique
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas gérer il est
là le problème c'est la pénalité
énergétique qui pose un problème
voilà donc à cause de ça tout ce que je
viens de dire c'est pas commode de faire
un rétro fit sur les centrales
existantes et bien évidemment c'est un
dispositif qui ne peut s'utiliser que
sur les sources concentré alors les gens
se concentrent et ça fait quand même un
paquet d'un paquet de sources 1 dans le
diagramme que je vous avais montré sur
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
vous rappeler par exemple 20% des
émissions mondiales ceux des centrales à
charbon
ça serait éligible 6% les cimenteries ça
serait éligible 7% les centrales à gaz
et en pétrole
ça serait éligible voilà donc vous avez
en gros 40%
on va dire des émissions mondiales qui
seraient éligibles mais c'est 40 % c'est
pas 100% mais je le redis
alors il par ailleurs comme ça un coup
et que ça a des conséquences très
importantes à la fois à l'amont et à
l'aval
aucun électricien ne fera jamais rien
dans les bon ordre de grandeur si on lui
en colle pas l'obligation donc la ccs
est quelque chose qui ne se développera
jamais de manière significative
s'il n'ya pas par voie réglementaire
l'obligation de le faire si ce n'est pas
obligatoire quelles qu'en soient les
conséquences ça ne se fera pas
alors ça revient à une obligation je
finirai secours en expliquant qu en fait
une manière de matérialiser la
contrainte ça peut arriver soit par un
prix soit par une réglementation est en
fait la réglementation ou matérialise un
coup d'ajustement donc c'est une forme
de prix mais un peu différent le vous
verrez la différence à la donc on peut
décarbonés avec la ccs est encore une
fois décarbonés avec les autres les
autres marge de manoeuvre sur la
production électrique on en parle dans
la prochaine fois après on peut faire de
l'efficacité à l'autre bout de la chaîne
et je vais vous donner quelques exemples
on peut parfaitement aujourd'hui
construire un bâtiment neuf qui soit
extrêmement performant pas
nécessairement n'importe où parce que
par exemple qu'il soit performant il
faut correctement l'orienter par rapport
au soleil si la parcelle où vous
construisez fait que l'orientation du
logement que vous allez construire vous
pouvez pas mettre la face sud au sud et
c'est parce que vous avez à part c'est
l'état s'ils disposent et que vous
pouvez pas dû prendre comme ça vous ne
pouvez pas nécessairement bénéficier de
tous les apports thermiques et donc
avoir un truc aussi efficace que ça que
ça devrait être
mais techniquement j'ai envie de dire
dans de bonnes conditions c'est pas très
difficile de faire ça ici vous avez par
exemple un exemple enfin vous avez une
maison passive en suède pas si ça veut
dire qu'il ya pas de dispositif de
chauffage et aude et en suède où il est
raisonnablement froid l'hiver donc ça va
alors en fait ça fait longtemps qu'on
améliore l'efficacité des bâtiments
notamment a qu à la suite du choc
pétrolier on a commencé à faire ça en
france
donc ici vous avez par exemple
le 1 logement qui date d'il ya quelques
dizaines d'années quand il avait un
chauffage central
il fait ils consomment plus de 200
kilowatts heure par mètre carré et par
an pour assurer son chauffage
après on a fait des logements qui
étaient plus efficaces et puis soit dit
en passant quand on fait des logements
collectifs
ce qui est le cas quand on organise et
biens intrinsèquement c'est plus
efficace et on est descendu à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres heure par mètre
carré et par an avant même de parler de
la réglementation actuelle donc vous
voyez que ont fait déjà des choses plus
efficace et on pourrait se dire du coup
on va faire des économies mais mais il
se trouve que dans le même temps
eh bien on a eu d'abord il ya un certain
nombre de bâtiments qui était pas
chauffé donc la performance intrinsèque
elle n'avait pas de sens puisque avait
pas de chauffage
si on leur donne un chauffage à ces
bâtiments existants on va augmenter la
consommation d'énergie ensuite on a
augmenté la surface habitable par
personne la surface habitable par
personne est aujourd'hui de quasiment 40
mètres carrés avant les chocs pétroliers
elle était de 25 23
ensuite on a augmenté le taux
d'équipement en tout cas pas de truc
c'est à dire que dans la maison de votre
grand mère quand elle avait votre âge ou
de votre grand père quand il avait votre
âge il n'y avait pas tout l'équipement
électroménager que vous trouvez
aujourd'hui dans votre logement à vous
ensuite on a évidemment augmenté la
quantité de logements ce qui fait que la
quantité d'énergie totale qu'on utilise
dans le bâtiment est resté à peu près
constante et la quantité d'énergie
fossiles qu'on utilise dans le bâtiment
n'a pas considérablement diminué elle a
changé de nature
vous avez moins de charbon utilisé plus
de charbon il ya quelques dizaines
d'années - de sioule plus de gaz est
plus d'électricité et eaux globalement
on utilise à peu près la même quantité
d'énergie aujourd'hui dans le bâtiment
que c'est le c'était le cas il ya
quelques dizaines d'années
par ailleurs il ya une chose qu'il faut
sortir de la tête souvent on entend dire
que le n'offrent en place de l'ancien
c'est pas vrai le neuf se rajoute à
l'ancien le en france on construit
chaque année quelques centaines de
milliers de logements on a un parc
existant qui est 30 millions de
résidences principales dont vous voyez
on pourrait se dire pourquoi c'est un
pur sang qu'on remplace chaque année en
fait non c'est important qu'on rajoute
chaque année qui correspond soit dit en
passant à l'accroissement naturel de la
population et au divorce est le vrai
taux de renouvellement
c'est plutôt de l'ordre de 1 pour mille
donc on ne peut pas compter sur la
rotation naturelle du parc en se disant
eh bien l'efficacité dans la
construction neuve fera le job sur le
parc existant
il suffit d'attendre en fait il ya très
peu de renouvellement du parc existe sur
les voitures c'est pareil on a fait des
progrès considérables sur une voiture
venait là vous voyez la voiture enfin
c'est presque la voiture dans laquelle
j'ai appris à conduire et ici vous voyez
la petite voiture on va dire delà de la
société de la société moderne
alors si vous regardez la quantité de
carburant consommé par litre de
cylindrée
on a fait d'énormes progrès si vous
regardez la quantité de carburant par
kilomètre heure de vitesse maximale on a
fait d'énormes progrès si vous regardez
la quantité de carburant consommée par
unité de puissance du moteur
on a fait d'énormes progrès et enfin si
vous regardez la quantité de carburant
consommé par kilo de masse on a aussi
fait d'énormes progrès sauf que l'engin
à gauche consommer 5 litres au cent et
lanjard à droite consomme 5 litres aux
cent
donc en fait ce qu'on a fait avec les
voitures c'est pas d'économiser sur une
voiture c'est d'augmenter la performance
à consommation constante c'est ça qu'on
a fait sur les voitures de même que sur
les bâtiments
puisqu'on a à peu près la même quantité
d'énergie consommée
pas tout à fait pour la même population
mais presque en ordre de grandeur
on a augmenté l'espace habitable et la
quantité d'équipement du logement à
consommation constante ce que laissée à
elle même et je vais généralisée ça
l'efficacité énergétique nous offrent en
général c'est un accroissement des
performances à consommation constante
voire à consommation croissante
parce que nous sommes en démocratie et
qu'on a droit d'acheter ce qu'on veut
oui
ses caisses
oui en l'occurrence à gauche c'était de
l'essence à droite c'est plutôt du
diesel mais peu importe c'est ce que
j'espère c'est le manque de grandeur si
on avait vraiment appliqués les
multiples que vous avez là on aurait
toujours des deux chevaux aujourd'hui
donc les voitures que vous auriez
plafonnerait à 90 km/heure ferait 500 kg
et effectivement elle consommerait de
livres mais c'est pas du tout ça qu'on a
fait c'est pas du tout ça qu'on a fait
dans le même temps le parc de véhicules
dans le monde augmente fortement
et du coup là vous l'avez pour le monde
dans son ensemble la quantité de
carburant que nous utilisons dans le
monde a tendance à augmenter
pour le moment donc la question de
savoir si on fait des économies est une
question intéressante est pour le moment
en fait la réponse dans le monde c'est
non on ne fait pas d'économies
sauf quand on est obligé bon en europe
on a déjà commencé à devenir un tout
petit peu des pauvres du pétrole tandis
qu'oddo me forcez vous avez ici je vous
l'avais déjà montré mais je vous le
reproche est l'approvisionnement
européen en pétrole depuis 1965
est ce que vous voyez c'est que depuis
2006 on a perdu quasiment 14%
d'approvisionnement pétrolier leurs
patients de temps ça c'est jusqu'en 2013
1014 là vous avez l'approvisionnement en
pétrole de schiste et le très forte en
euros le prix du pétrole étant très
fortement remonté à partir de 2008
vous avez à la fois le pétrole de
schiste qui se met à produire de manière
importante parce que les prix du pétrole
sont élevées tout un tas de projets
notamment dans la mer du nord qui
consiste à mieux racler les réservoirs
qui sont mis en oeuvre et donc
l'approvisionnement domestiques se remet
à légèrement croître
l'approvisionnement mondial se remet à
légèrement croître et du coup l'europe
repart légèrement à la hausse
mais comme je voulais dire au moment du
cours sur le pétrole ça va pas durer
éternellement
et du coup ce que vous voyez ici c'est
la quantité de carburant que nous
utilisons en france et vous voyez que en
fait on est passé par un maximum au
début des années 2000 et depuis c'est
raisonnablement stable
en très très léger déclin mais en gros
s'est raisonnablement stable
donc en fait la quantité de carburant
qu'on consomme en europe et en france en
particulier a déjà commencé à se tasser
mais là ça se fait j'ai envie de dire
sous la contrainte
1 c'est pas de l'efficacité c'est pas de
la sobriété c'est une forme de pauvreté
parce que on ne peut plus changer le
passé parce que ça et ceci alors avec
cela vous avez ici le trafic
marchandises
donc la quantité de marchandises
chargées dans les camions dont vous
voyez qu'elle est passée par un maximum
en 2007
je vous avais j'ai pu si je vous l'avais
montré la 1ère fois mais sinon j'aurais
pu vous montrer aussi la production
industrielle européenne c'est pareil à
passer par un maximum en 2007 la
construction en europe est passée par un
maximum en 2007 donc en 2000 en europe
on a commencé à faire des économies
obligent et ça s'appelle de la pauvreté
et à cause de ce que raconte mon
équation de kaya c'est déjà en train de
s'appliquer aux flux physiques de la
production et du coup à la contrepartie
monétaire de ces flux physiques
alors voilà un autre exemple toujours
dans les économies d'énergie ici vous
avez le frigo de l'américain est de
l'américaine en 1950
ça consomme quelques centaines de
kilowatts heure par an et sa possède 100
litres de capacité
ici vous avez le frigo que vous trouvez
chez un revendeur que je ne nommerai pas
aujourd'hui ça consomme toujours
quelques centaines de kilowatts heure
par an un peu moins en l'occurrence par
contre la capacité a été triplé et à
tiers de cette capacité est à -18 alors
qu'à l'époque c'était entre 5 et 10 de
veille
donc voilà donc à nouveau on a fait
énormément d'économies si on regarde un
trio
voilà mon premier ordinateur dont je
vous avais parlé au moment du cours sur
le changement climatique donc leygnac
voilà il a quelques il a un peu moins de
20 me de david
il a un poids confortable quelques
dizaines de tonnes et il consomme 100
kilowatts d'électricité
c'est un très très gros radiateur dans
l'ordinateur dont je suis en train de me
servir
il fait 2 kg un peu plus de 2 kg il a
des dizaines de millions de transistors
et il consomme 20 watts donc que vous
regardiez par l'unité de poids par unité
logique parents etc
on a gagné un facteur absolument
hallucinant en ce qui concerne
l'efficacité d'un ordinateur
cet ordinateur est plus puissant qu'un
supercalculateur des années 70 puis là
on utilisait pour aller sur la lune mais
dans le même temps les gens se sont un
tout petit peu équipés voyez en tout et
n'importe quoi donc en frigo en
ordinateur en un chien en lançant un et
quand vous regardez la quantité
d'électricité utilisée dans les
bâtiments en france
et bien voilà à quoi ça ressemble vous
voyez l'essentiel de cette augmentation
c'est pas du chauffage
c'est tout le reste c'est tous les
appareils électriques que vous trouvez
aujourd'hui dans les logements chacun
d'entre eux étant considérablement plus
efficace que celui qu'on avait ya
content quand il existait quand il
n'existait donc chacun d'entre eux est
considérablement plus efficace il
n'empêche que vous voyez que c'est
absolument pas des économies en valeur
absolue qu'on a fait si je regarde à
l'échelle de la planète
vous avez ici la quantité d'électricité
qui est utilisé
donc produite sur terre depuis 1945 on
voyait en 1945 ce que vous savez quelle
est la production électrique de la
france actuellement si vous aviez été
attentif avec un calcul d'heures de
vendeurs ou le feriez vous retrouveriez
550 térawattheures la production
électrique actuelle de la france c'est
550 térawattheures 550 milliards de
kilowattheures la production électrique
mondiale en 1945
vous voyez c'était un peu plus de six
ans donc retenu qu'en ordre de grandeur
la terre entière utilisait autant
d'électricité que la france en produit
aujourd'hui en 1945 l'électricité pour
tous c'est la marque de la deuxième
moitié du 20e siècle
même la première moitié du 20e siècle ne
connaissais pas ça il commençait à y
avoir d'électricité dans les maisons
bourgeoises et dans quelques endroits
mais voilà ils pourront faire un fond
ces quelques métro mais l'électricité
pour tous
à cette époque ça n'existait pas si on
fait un zoom plus récents voilà à quoi
ressemble la quantité d'électricité
utilisée dans le monde
sur les trente dernières années en gros
ce que vous voyez c'est qu'une bonne
partie de l'ain crémant pas tous hein
la zone ocde a augmenté sa consommation
etc mais là vous voyez l'essor de la
chine qui est absolument spectaculaire
en ce qui concerne l'électricité et le
reste des émergents que voyez là
également et l'électricité c'est une
énergie finale qui est particulièrement
difficile à faire baisser par unité de
pib alors me demandez pas pourquoi parce
que j'ai pas encore regarder dans le
détail mais vous avez ici une courbe qui
vous donne la quantité d'électricité qui
est utilisé dans le monde danse et une
moyenne mondiale par dollar de valeur
ajoutée et donc par dollars de pib
il ya ce que vous constituez ce que vous
constatez pardon c'est que sur la durée
de cette série c'est à dire sur un peu
plus de 30 ans cette valeur est à aux
oscillations près rigoureusement
constante il n'y a strictement
aucun gain d'efficacité électrique par
dollar de pipe sur les trente dernières
années
donc le la conclusion de ce petit
passage sur les appareils
c'est qu' il faut faire très attention
quand on parle économie d'énergie à ne
pas confondre deux choses qu'on confond
en permanence qui sont l'efficacité
unitaire c'est à dire combien je gagne
par appareil ou par usage et
l'efficacité globale c'est à dire est ce
que je suis capable de faire baisser
globalement ma consommation d'énergie
rien qu'avec cette efficacité est ce que
vous voyez c'est que sur la même durée
et en fait depuis qu'on fait des séries
statistiques on a en permanence en même
temps une efficacité qui s'améliore un
peu dans le même temps qu'une quantité
globale utilisée augmente
or si vous vous placez du point de vue
soit de l'atmosphère soit des stocks de
combustible fossile
ce qui compte c'est pas la consommation
par appareil c'est la totalité soit de
ce que vous taper dans le stock soit de
ce que vous mettez dans l'atmosphère
l'atmosphère se contrefiche de nos
émissions par aspirateur de nos
émissions par voiture plus exactement ça
l'intéresse par l'atmosphère est ce
qu'elle voit c'est la quantité totale de
co2 qui arrive de même qu'un réservoir
de pétrole
la consommation par voiture ou la
consommation par chaudière il s'en fiche
ce qu'ils voient c'est la quantité
totale qu'on va prendre dans le
réservoir
donc ce qui fait ce qui doit être
baissés si on parle économie c'est soit
les émissions totales
si on parle du climat soit la
consommation totale de combustibles
fossiles
si on parle d'énergie c'est bien ça qui
doit être baissés et le grand drame de
ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à maintenant c'est
que à quelques exceptions près tout ce
qu'on a fait en efficacité unitaire a
toujours été plus que compensée par une
augmentation des usages
toujours tout le temps dit autrement en
compte et juste sur les ingénieurs ont
ne réglemente pas les usages et quelque
chose qui ne marche pas ça ne marche pas
comme ça marche pas
alors ce qui marche c'est de coller des
contraintes et c'est de ça dont on va
parler à partir de maintenant vous avez
ici les émissions de co2 de la france
que je vous avait déjà montré mais que
je vais vous remonterez avec une autre
lecture
au regard de ce que je viens de vous
dire vous les avez discriminés dans un
certain nombre de secteurs donc là vous
voyez on est pendant les trente
glorieuses jusqu'à la fin jusqu'au choc
pétrolier tout augmente puisque en fait
l'économie croît fortement parce que on
a de plus en plus d'énergie à
disposition et donc les émissions de co2
qui vont derrière au monde parte et puis
en 1973
on a tout d'un coup un énorme signal
prix qui arrive sur le pétrole alors à
ce moment vous voyez deux secteurs qui
vont réagir très rapidement
le premier secteur qui réagit très
rapidement c'est l'industrie oui
l'industrie avait des émissions qui
croissait immédiatement ces émissions se
mettent à décroître
je l'avais déjà dit dans un cours
précédent mais je le redis dans les
industries et plus généralement dans le
monde économique
vous avez une rationalité à l'oeuvre qui
est beaucoup plus élevé que dans les
ménages les votre comportement en tant
qu'individu chez vous êtes un
comportement qui n'est pas un
comportement avant tout dictés par des
calculs économiques
c'est pas avant tout dictés par ça quand
vous êtes au travail c'est différent là
l'indicateur économique est un
indicateur beaucoup plus cardinal dans
le
j'ai envie dire les signaux et le
pilotage de votre activité
donc là les gens commencent à faire des
calculs se disent où le pétrole ça vaut
cher il est abstrait qui valent moins
cher et puis à d'état d'économie qui
sont rentables
et puis et c'est donc craque on se met à
économiser qui au moment où arrive le
deuxième choc on en rajoute une couche
après vous voyez qu'il ya un autre
secteur dans lequel la la décrue va
arriver très vite après le deuxième choc
c'est le secteur industrie de l'énergie
industries de l'énergie ces deux trucs
là dedans c'est les raffineries et les
centrales électriques les raffineries
si on commence à utiliser moins de
pétrole au moins à raffiner du coup
elles émettent moins pas très compliqué
à comprendre
et la deuxième chose qui va se passer
c'est la mise en route du programme
nucléaire français qui avaient commencé
à toute petite vitesse avant et là
auxquels on donne à franges
un énorme coup d'accélérateur et ça ça
vous fait très fortement baisser les
émissions de la production et après vous
avez un troisième secteur dont vous
voyez que il réagit un peu c'est les
chaudières de bâtiments et là c'est
pareil on était en train de mai des
chaudières à fuel partout à il le choc
pétrolier on arrête de mettre des
chaudières à fuel partout et on se met à
mettre des radiateurs électriques
partout et des chaudières à gaz partout
et là vous voyez que craque ça permet
également de faire baisser les émissions
il ya un secteur dont vous voyez qu'il
passe à travers ces deux chocs et ça lui
fait à peu près ni chaud ni froid
c'est les transports est en fait la
raison pour laquelle les transports
passe à travers cette évolution sans que
cela fasse ni chaud ni froid
c'est que dans les transports vous avez
essentiellement des individus c'est à
dire vous au volant de votre voiture est
à ce moment votre rationalité économique
n'est pas suffisante pour que vous
fassiez d'état de calculs savants en
vous disant j'achète pas la voiture et
je vais plutôt aller à pied en vélo ça
me coûtera moins cher et prendre le
train l'été c'est pas du tout comme ça
vous raisonnez et donc de fait ce prix
là l'augmentation de prix n'est pas
suffisante surtout qu'elle était
transitoire pour casser la dynamique
d'accès à la voiture surtout en période
d'urbanisation croissante et
d'augmentation des couronnes
périurbaines
il faudra attendre la contrainte
physique sur l'approvisionnement
européen et français pour que du côté
des automobilistes et des camionneurs
on commence à entendre raison donc vous
voyez vous avez deux contraintes qui ont
été à l'oeuvre dans ce graphique et qui
l ont engendré des économies en
l'occurrence de co2 en valeur absolue un
signal prix et une réglementation qui a
commencé à être un peu significatifs par
exemple à ce moment là on applique une
réglementation thermique aux bâtiments
qui sont construits on a des programmes
d'économie d'énergie qui se met en route
etc
et puis ici la contrainte physique qui
fait qu'il y en a plus assez pour que ça
continue à augmenter donc à ce moment ça
peut pas augmenter alors sur les
transports vous voyez ici qu'on a
l'impression que cela passe totalement à
travers alors en fait si on regarde avec
une loupe un indicateur plus précis on
se rend compte que ça passe pas
complètement à travers
mais c'est sur une durée trop courte
pour que ça puisse avoir un effet vous
avez ici le prix du pétrole
exprimée en dollars constants ce que je
vous avait déjà montré sur indo
graphique alors ma série va pas jusqu'à
aujourd'hui mais ce n'est pas nécessaire
parce que je vais vous expliquer et ici
vous avez dans les pays de l' ocde la
consommation aux 100 kilomètres des
véhicules neufs vendus dans l'année donc
quand ça baisse c'est que ça veut dire
que année après année les véhicules
qu'on a vendu consomme un peu moins que
ceux de l'année précédente
c'est ça que ça veut dire quand ça
baisse pas ça veut dire que année après
année les véhicules qu'on a vendu
consomme autant que ce qu'on a vendu
l'année précédente simple
de 1979 à 1985
nous sommes en période de prix du
pétrole hors de prix des carburants très
élevé parce qu'en fait les pouvoirs
politiques à ce moment là les prix sont
encadrés ils mettent quelques années à
rattraper la hausse du prix du baril ils
font passer en un seul coup et donc ils
ont des prix des carburants qui sont
élevés voire croissant et bien vous
voyez que à ce moment là entre 60 79 et
85 dans tous les pays de l' ocde
les consommateurs achètent année après
année quand il achète une voiture neuve
elle consomme en moyenne un peu moins
que ce qu'elle consomme l année
précédente
et au moment où arrive le contrechoc
c'est d'ailleurs de nouveau la
stabilisation du prix du pétrole à un
prix relativement bas
tous les consommateurs s'arrête d'être
vertueux quel que soit le pays concerné
donc ce que vous voyez là c'est un autre
une autre traduction de ce qu'on appelle
le signal prix à partir du moment où on
colle une contrainte et monter le prix
des carburants c'est une contrainte et
bien la consommation réagi et là en
l'occurrence la façon dont ça réagisse
et que les consommateurs achètent des
véhicules qui consomment un peu moins en
je fais le parc de voitures en france et
la moitié de ce qu'il est aujourd'hui la
moitié donc vous avez beaucoup moins la
différence avec ce qu'on devrait faire
aujourd'hui où ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
c'est que vous avez beaucoup moins de
gens qui habitent dans des couronnes
périurbaines et qui sont tributaires de
la voiture pour aller au travail
c'est une population qui est beaucoup
plus faible ou bien les urbains sont
urbain à paris vous balader à pied donc
si vous avez plus de voiture à paris je
suis arrivé très bien c'est pas un sujet
et même si vous n'avez plus de voitures
à neuilly ou plus de voitures
1 qu'est ce que je veux dire à
saint-denis ou si on vivait très bien
par contre si vous n'avez pas de voiture
à meaux et que vous avez un travail à
saint quentin en yvelines vous survivez
un peu moins bien et cette population-là
a fortement augmenté depuis 1974
et c'est là que vous allez trouver les
gens qui ont commencé à protester quand
tu es prix du carburant sont devenus
élevé il ya quelques mois ce qu'on
appelle le gilet jaune vous aller les
trouver dans des endroits qui ont été
créés depuis 1974 de forte dépendance à
la voiture en droit qui existe est
beaucoup moins à l'époque des chocs
pétroliers pour ça qu'il ya eu moins de
oui c'est pas la question
non non non non c'est juste une réaction
signal prix je vais vous montrer un
deuxième graphique qui vous dit
exactement la même chose ici vous avez
la quantité de carburant consommés par
personne et par an dans un certain
nombre de pays en fonction du prix des
carburants à la pompe dans ce même pays
et ce graphique là il est fait à la fin
des années enfin à la fin du xxème
siècle c'est à dire à un moment où les
prix du pétrole n'ont pas reçu bilal
envolée qu'ils ont subie au début du 21e
siècle jusqu'en jusqu'en 2008 et à ce
moment là les à l'exception des chocs
pétroliers les prix du pétrole
enfin les prix des carburants paraît
plus exactement à la pompe reflète la
fiscalité locale dans le pays sur
période longue
dit autrement les prix des carburants
ont été soit durablement chère soit
durablement pas cher dans un certain
nombre de pays en fonction de la
politique fiscale du pays est ce que
vous voyez c'est que en gros plus la
politique fiscale du pays a été de taxer
les carburants et moins les gens en
consomment et le système évidemment
s'adapte quand vous lui laisser le temps
donc quand pendant longtemps les prix de
carburants sont chers à ce moment les
constructeurs fabriquent des petites
voitures
c'est la raison pour laquelle en europe
où on a démarré notre histoire
pétrolières comme importateur de pétrole
donc ça nous coûte cher on a mis des
réglementations forte
pardon les constructeurs se sont imposés
d une efficacité forte sur les moteurs
parce qu'ils savent que leurs clients
peuvent pas acheter énormément de
carburant on a beaucoup taxer encore une
fois pour éviter d'en consommer beaucoup
aidé on a un système vertueux qui se met
en place dans lequel on fait des petites
voitures consommant pas beaucoup alors
que dans les pays qui ont démarré leur
histoire comme producteurs de carburants
typiquement les états unis comme ça
coule à flot le truc vaut pas cher du
coup on fait des grosses voitures et les
gens en consomment beaucoup alors ce
système là ça marche bien quand vous
laisser le temps à la population de
s'ajuster
si vous avez un ajustement trop rapide
que vous imposer à la population
à ce moment vous créez non pas le
phénomène des gilets jaunes mais enfin
l'équivalent c'est à dire une partie de
la population qui n'a pas le temps de
s'ajuster par exemple qui n'a pas le
temps de renouveler sa voiture avec une
voiture d'occasion parce que c'est des
gens qui achètent pas des voitures
neuves
qui consomment beaucoup moins ce qui
veut dire que la voiture d'occasion elle
doit être vendue depuis longtemps ce qui
veut dire qu'elle a dû être acheté par
quelqu'un d'autre qui avait une raison
de l'acheter alors quel concept pas
beaucoup et c'est que vous avez tout un
système qui doit se mettre en place et
ça prend du temps donc si vous lui
laisser le temps de s'ajuster ça marche
bien
sinon à très court terme le système et
le système ça justement gains et si vous
faites une petite régression sur ce
nuage de points vous arriver à la
conclusion pour diviser la quantité de
carburant par cat il faut le multiplier
et le prix par quatre voilà donc ça vous
donne une petite idée de la conviendra
montée prix de l'essence
si on doit passer par un signal prix si
on doit passer par un signal prix sur le
prix de l'essence
en gros si on veut diviser la quantité
de carburant utilisé en france par
quatre rien qu'avec une taxe carbone il
faut que les sens passe à 6 euros le
litre
voilà donc je vous laisse apprécier de
la facilité qu'il y à mettre ça en
oeuvre a raisonnablement brefs délais
sachant qu'il ya une autre manière
d'arriver exactement au même résultat
qui est de réglementer
je peux très bien dire à partir de
demain matin
enfin pas demain matin parce qu'il faut
le temps que les constructeurs s'ajuste
mais à partir de dans cinq ans il est
interdit de vendre en france une voiture
qui consomme plus de deux litres aux
cent je peux dire ça à ce moment le le
parc français va voir sa consommation
diminuer par trois alors j'ai les
mesures d'ajustement à m notamment dès
que je dis ça les voitures d'occasion
qui consomment plus de dole ils vont se
déprécier énormément donc il faut que je
prévois des primes à la casse pour les
sortir à vitesse accélérée du parc etc
notamment pour les gens qui ont pas
beaucoup d'argent mais avec des mesures
d'ajustement de cette nature je suis
capable d'aller beaucoup plus vite
qu'avec une augmentation du prix du
carburant donc il ya pas que et c'est la
question avait été posée tout à l'heure
une réglementation ça peut aussi mettre
une contrainte qui est très efficace sur
un système j'ai pas il n'y a pas que
signal prix qui y perd un tiers sans bon
ça je veux pas c'est parce que j'ai pas
le temps
quand on passe par le signal prix on
peut être poussé à faire des gestes mais
là je vais prendre un autre exemple d'un
signal-prix où ça suffit pas qui est
l'isolation des bâtiments
vous avez ici le coup quelque part le
coup au kilowattheure hérité d'un
certain nombre de gestes que vous pouvez
faire sur le bâtiment
vous voyez qui sont décrits l'a donc la
hauteur de la barre c'est le coup du
geste la gradation sur l'horizontale
c'est le gisement dit autrement la
quantité d'énergie que je peux
économiser avec ce geste là et ici vous
avez combien coûte aujourd'hui l'énergie
qui est facturé au malawi s'appelle de
la pluie vous avez combien coûte
l'énergie qui est facturé aux ménages et
bien c'est pareil
vous voyez pour que les gestes qui sont
sur la droite du graphique là deviennent
rentables avec simplement une hausse du
prix de l'énergie facturés aux ménages
il faudrait que ce prix soit multipliée
par quatre alors une première option
c'est de multiplier les prix par quatre
et puis les gens ont changé ou pas une
deuxième option c'est de les rendre
obligatoires de dire aux propriétaires
c'est obligatoire de faire ça et puis si
vous le faites pas et bien ou bien vous
n'avez pas le droit de vendre ou bien je
vous massacre au niveau des impôts
fonciers or voilà pouvait très bien donc
il n'y a pas que le signal prix encore
une fois c'est une c'est une option mais
ce n'est pas la seule
après oui
le signal
vous voulez
oui
j'y viendrai après en fait parler de
prix ça peut désigner
soit un prix explicite c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui vous demande de payer
quelque chose au titre de la nuisance
d'accord vous émettez une tonne de co2
savent autant
ou bien ça peut être un coup
d'ajustement c'est à dire vous et je
vous interdit d'émettre la tonne de co2
et à ce moment est-ce que vous allez
devoir payer pour vous organiser pour ne
pas les mettre c'est ça le prix si je
vous dis il est interdit d'avoir une
chaudière à fioul chez vous parce que ça
avait trop de co2 pour vous chauffer
donc voilà la prochaine fois que ça
tombe en panne vous la remplacez par ce
que vous voulez mais pas une chaudière
fioul eh bien vous avez un coup
d'ajustement qui est le coût de la
nouvelle chaudière versus le coût de la
chaudière à fuel ou plus exactement du
brûleur que vous alliez simplement
remplacé d'accord si je vous dis par
exemple c'est obligatoire de remplacer
votre chaudière fioul par une pompe à
chaleur
la prochaine fois que ça tombe en panne
vous avez un coup d'ajustement donc le
l'interdiction d'émettre du co2 avec
votre chaudière à fuel se matérialise
pas à part ça va vous coûter trop cher
de payer le fuel
ça se matérialise par je vous interdit
de garder votre chaudière est à ce
moment c'est ce que vous devez payer
pour avoir autre chose
dans tous les cas de figure il ya de
l'argent qui transitent
mais il va pas nécessairement au même
endroit et il concerne pas
nécessairement le même objet
soit dit en passant quand alors plus
généralement quand on parle de prix du
co2 donc c'est à ça que j'avais venir il
peut se passe ça peut désigner une des
grandes heures suivantes ça peut
désigner dans le système européen de
quotas de co2 ce que vous devez payer
pour en acquérir un corps je veux
revenir après sur ce que sur ce que ce
soit à quelqu'un d'autre soit à l'état
ça peut représenter le paiement d'une
taxe ça ça peut aussi s'appeler un prix
du co2 par exemple la taxe carbone en
france
c'est un prix du co2 fiscale d'accord
vous acheter un litre de carburant dans
le litre de carburant et à 3 kg de co2
et bien si le prix du co2 ces 30 euros
la tonne vous allez devoir payer ce 9
centimes de taxe
si on vous dit vous devez faire avec
moins de co2 réglementairement ce prix
du co2 en fait peut être un coup d'
ajustement donc c'est l'exemple que j'ai
développée en dix ans et le remplacement
de votre chaudière à fuel par autre
chose ça peut aussi désigner quelques
fois la chatte ce qui va permettre
d'émettre du co2 en prix de marché par
exemple si vous achetez un litre de
pétrole
de fait c'est l'achat d'un droit à
polluer c'est à dire c'est l'achat du
droit de brûler ce litre de pétrole et
donc d'émettre du co2 on peut considérer
que le prix du co2 est inclus c'est une
partie de ce prix d'achat donc quand on
parle de prix du co2 ça peut désigner
plein de types de prix différents et il
n'y a pas dans tous les cas de figure le
même récipient en verre ce n'est pas au
même endroit que va l'argent si vous
avez besoin d'acheter une nouvelle
chaudière s'est pas l'état qui perçoit
l'argent par contre si vous avez une
taxe carbone sur le diesel c'est l'état
qui perçoit l'argent si vous achetez un
quota à un autre industriel qui en a
trop c'est à l'autre industrielle que va
l'argent corps donc l'argent ne va pas
au même endroit en fonction de ce qu'on
désigne comme étant un prix du co2 et en
pratique
si vous achetez un quota parce que vous
êtes un site
alors pardon je déconne tout de suite un
peu précise que c'est qu'un quota à
quotas c'est dans le système européen
une autorisation administrative des
maîtres que vous pouvez acheter aux
enchères
si vous avez une cimenterie votre
cimenterie on lui dit chaque année vous
avez le droit d'émettre temps de co2
évidemment ça va en décroissant donc
cette année un million de tonnes l'année
prochaine 950000 etc
eh bien ces tonnes de co2 ou bien vous
les acheter aux enchères à l'état pour
avoir le droit de faire fonctionner
votre cimenteries ou bien vous les
achetez en prix négociés de gré à gré
sur un marché à quelqu'un d'autre à qui
on en a donné trop et qu'il n'a pas
besoin d'autant donc si vous achetez
votre quota c'est à dire votre
autorisation administrative des mettre
aux enchères au début de la partie si
elle est akbar l'argent si vous
l'achetez à quelqu'un d'autre qui est
dans le système et qui en a trop c'est à
lui que va l'argent si vous avez un prix
de marché d'un hydrocarbure qui augmente
c'est aux pays producteurs que va
l'argent si vous avez un coup
d'ajustement c'est à la personne qui
vous fournit l'équipement ou la nouveau
le le nouveau dispositif que va l'argent
donc l'argent va pas toujours au même
endroit pour finir avec un ordre de
grandeur sur
prix du pétrole versus taxe carbone si
on augmente un truc qu'il faut retenir
c'est que si on augmente le prix du
baril de 50 dollars c'est en gros comme
si on crée une taxe carbone à 100 euros
la tonne alors maintenant petite
question à partir du moment où du
pétrole il y en aura pas de plus en plus
pour tout le monde pour l'éternité
même s'il n'ya pas d'élasticité de long
terme de temps en temps il va y avoir
des augmentations de prix significatives
au moment où le prix augmente c'est
comme si l'automobiliste français payent
une taxe carbone mais au lieu de le
payer à l'état français
il la paye à l'état russe algérien
angolais et c'est donc en fait au motif
qu'il veux pas enrichir ces abrutis de
fonctionnaires français qui ne font rien
ça veut dire qu'on accepte un peu plus
tard d'enrichir les fonctionnaires des
autres qui évidemment sont beaucoup plus
soucieux de nos intérêts il faut bien
comprendre que dans un système dans
lequel de temps en temps l'insuffisance
quantitative se traduit par des
augmentations de prix
refuser la taxe carbone qui consiste à
se modérer de nous-mêmes avec de
l'argent qu'ils restent dans le pays
c'est accepter une taxe carbone dont le
produit
fischer alcan en des frontières
après la bonne question c'est comment
est-ce que j'aide les gens qui sont
vraiment dans la mouise ci doivent la
payer à s'organiser autrement ce qui est
évidemment là votre question bondir au
gilet jaune vous allez payer votre
carburant plus cher mais moi je me suis
pas creuser la cervelle avance pour
savoir comment vous alliez pouvoir plus
facilement covoiturer prendre un vélo un
train ou en bus
évidemment que les gens sont pas
contents et ils ont raison mais par
contre dire à jamais tout jamais
j'augmenterais jamais le prix des
carburants ça par contre c'est se
condamner à ce que périodiquement on est
la balance commerciale qui soit un peu
plus déséquilibré avec de l'argent qui
part chez les autres et quand l'argent
par chez les autres parce que déficit
commercial de sa croix la macroéconomie
vous dit que le pib baisse et chômage
augmente par une très bonne idée par
rapport au fait de taxer les carburants
directement chez nous et garder l'argent
pendant voilà je vais finir avec un
exemple alors ça c'est un ce que je vais
vous montrer maintenant est un petit un
petit badge est de mesure que on a
essayé de pousser au chiffre project
donc c'est ma partie infiltré dans ce
court non je vais pas vous le montrer en
disant c'est ça qu'il faut faire je vais
juste vous le montrer en dix ans pour
les mesures que je propose aux chiffres
voilà en gros le type d'instruments
régulatoire qu'on propose d'employer
pour que vous compreniez encore une fois
qu'il n'ya pas juste la taxe carbone qui
fait le job et qu'il ya des tas d'autres
instruments qui sont employables pour
mettre en oeuvre des économies d'énergie
ici vous avez la décomposition des des
émissions européennes par grands blocs
alors dans les industries de l'énergie
et par d'adam d'électricité les
centrales à charbon à elle toute seule
font 20 % c'est marrant en europe comme
dans le monde
dans les transports les voitures à elle
toute seule font 10 % dans l'industrie
l'industrie de base à elle toute seule
fait un gros 15 % et enfin dans
l'alimentation les vaches à elle toute
seule fonds 6 8%
alors on a conçu un ensemble de mesures
qui nous paraissent comment dire
obligatoire si on veut être sérieux sur
la question si vous voulez diviser les
émissions par trois vous ne pouvez pas
faire l'impasse de ne pas vous attaquer
aux premiers postes de chacun
le camembert c'est juste de
l'arithmétique de base vous pouvez pas
diviser les émissions par trois en vous
occupant que des trombones donc à partir
du moment où on veut diviser les
émissions par trois on est obligé de
taper dans le dur le dur il est
notamment la la la et là il ya d'autres
mesures je vais vous en parler
rapidement et alors ce qu'on a on pousse
quand on dit il faut s'occuper
sérieusement de la question en europe
la première chose qu'on dise et il faut
fermer les centrales à charbon alors les
centrales à charbon pour les fermer et
les remplacer par du décarbonée on le
décarbonés vous aimez le nucléaire vous
mettez du nucléaire vous n'avez pas le
nucléaire vous mettez les éoliennes ça
va vous coûter dix fois plus cher et on
s'en fout faites ce que vous voulez mais
plus de centrales à charbon
le ca vous pouvez le faire par voie
d'augmentation des prix vous mettez une
taxe sur l'électricité au charbon c'est
ce qu'ont fait les anglais ça revient à
augmenter le prix des quotas avec un
prix plancher dire que vous pouvez pas
les acquérir à moins d'un certain prix
qui augmentent avec le temps ce quasi
taxe ça marche
les anglais l'ont fait vous pouvez aussi
le faire de manière réglementaire les
états unis autant d'obama on dit il est
interdit de construire une nouvelle
centrale électrique dont les émissions
soient supérieures à une livre de co2
par kilowattheure alors comme le charbon
ont fait 2 c'est à dire 1 kg ça
interdisait deux fêtes de construire de
nouvelles centrales à charbon ce qui
veut dire qu'au moment où les centrales
à charbon actuel arrive en fin de vie
vous pouvez pas les remplacer par des
nouvelles centrales à charbon eh bien
vous voyez un à ma gauche
j'ai une possibilité par le prix la taxe
à ma droite
j'ai une possibilité réglementaire quel
est le meilleur instrument sont faut
regarder mais on peut pas dire a priori
il ya que le prix qui va fonctionner
peut-être que l'instrument réglementaire
marchera encore mieux et vous pouvez
faire encore plus violent comme on fait
sur le nucléaire
ceci a créé sur le nucléaire on s'est
pas posé la question de savoir si en
allemagne les centrales était
compétitive pas compétitive violence il
faut poser la question de savoir si
fessenheim était compétitive par
compétitif et il n'est pas qualifié soit
dit en passant pour dire que c'est
dangereux c'est l'asn qu'il est donc il
a juste dit je faire il a décidé comme
ça donc réglementairement
vous pouvez très bien aussi fermer les
centrales à charbon c'est des
installations qui ont besoin
d'autorisation d'exploitation délivrée
pas l'autorisation sa ferme donc vous
avez vous voyez soit larmes du prix soit
la revue réglementaire et les deux
peuvent fonctionner en ce qui concerne
les voitures il ya une mesure qui
aujourd'hui est une mesure réglementaire
donc je vous en ai parlé qui permettrait
de faire baisser la consommation des
voitures c'est d'interdire à la vente
des voitures qui consomment plus de
temps ça c'est une mesure réglementaire
vous pouvez monter le prix des
carburants et attendre que les
constructeurs et les conducteurs
s'adapte c'est une autre façon de
procéder
vous pouvez avoir une troisième mesure
fiscale que vous pouvez mettre en oeuvre
qui est d'avoir un impôt à la détention
on a eu ça en france ça s'appelait la
vignette la vignette c'est un malus
annuel
c'est très simple donc vous avez une
voiture plus elle consomme plus chaque
année c'est comme un impôt foncier mais
sur la voiture
chaque année vous payez une taxe sur
votre voiture et elle est d'autant plus
élevé que la voiture est grosse bon bah
vous faites ça vous interdisez pas aux
gens qui ont vraiment besoin d'avoir une
voiture pour aller au boulot d'acheter
une toute petite voiture qui consomme
pas et avec laquelle ils vont payer une
taxe annuelle très faible voire vous
pouvez les aider à acheter une voiture
qui consomme pas et dans le même temps
tous les gens qui ont quoi que ce soit
de superflu boom où les assassiner et à
ce moment vous allez avoir une
disparition assez rapide du parc des
voitures qui consomment plus de temps
donc là vous voyez vous avez trois
instruments à votre disposition vous
pouvez en rajouter d'autres de nature
réglementaire par exemple rendent
difficile le parking tous les gens qui
vont au travail en voiture en région
parisienne c'est parce qu'ils ont une
place de parking à destination vouloir
supprimer la place de parking à
destination ils font n'importe quoi mais
il s'adapte donc vous avez voilà donc
vous à vous avez encore une fois il n'ya
pas que le signal prix qui est soit dit
en passant il faut que ça aille avec
autre chose qui est d'avoir une mesure
alternative
donc mon gilet jaune qui fait 25 bornes
en bagnole pour aller au travail
si le prix de carburant devient
inaccessible il va pas en faire 22 et
faire les trois derniers kilomètres à
pied l'autoroute pas ça qui va faire il
va descendre dans la rue en disant
arrêtez moi cette taxe carbone si vous
voulez qu'ils aillent un peu moins en
voiture au travail à ce moment il faut
mettre en place des systèmes qui
permettent de mutualiser les moyens de
transport typiquement alors ça
et ni la réglementation vers le
consommateur ni de la réglementation
verdun vers le constructeur c'est de la
planification la planification ça a
était l'heure de gloire de l'état
français et c'est encore autre chose
c'est-à-dire que vous donnez des règles
du jeu aux gens qui organisent au
constructeur d'infrastructures aux
exploitants d'infrastructures aux élus
locaux etc corse et à ces gens là que
vous allez donner les règles du jeu ces
deux nouveaux réglementaire mais c'est
pas directement vers le point vers le
consommateur final que vous êtes anglais
alors bon ça c'était un truc moins
d'avions plus de trains soit dit en
passant il ya une proposition
actuellement défendue par rufin pour
ceux d'entre vous qui n'ont vu passer
qui dit qu' il propose d'interdire les
vols en avion dès que vous pouvez y
aller en train à moins de cinq heures
bon ça sort pas de cette salle mais je
suis tout à fait favorable
selon l' aider à faire la proposition en
question et les gens qu'ils eurent donc
le alors là la raison pour laquelle on
avait bâti cette proposition c'était
parce que vous vous rappelez peut-être
que l'europe a été construite pour qu'on
arrête de faire la guerre
j'ai la chance d'être né dans un monde
qui l'a jamais connu la guerre enfin sur
mon propre sol mes parents n'ont pas
connu ça mais grands parents encore
moins 1 2 qui sont morts mes arrière
grands parents non plus donc vous avez
cette chance aussi c'est pas si vous
vous rendez compte de ce que ça
représente
mais c'est extrêmement précieux et
l'europe a été fait pour garder un monde
en pleine notamment sur la base des
échanges et donc on s'est dit c'est
quand il ya moins de pétrole ya moins
d'avions si on veut garder des échanges
croquer quelques trains donc là c'est
pareil
vous ne vous n'arriverez pas à
simplement par les prix de marché à
faire en sorte que les constructeurs
d'infrastructures face des
infrastructures qui sont des trucs qui
vont durer un siècle et avec n'importe
quel taux d'actualisation c'est pas
rentable je veux dire il faut qu'il ait
une volonté politique de le faire dans
l'industrie lourde
allez je vous la fais à la grosse compte
tenu du fait que l'efficacité
énergétique est très très difficile à
gagner
enfin vous gagnerez pas un facteur 3 il
faut en gros limiter la production de
matériaux de base
un facteur 3 il faut le divisé par un
facteur 3 offert trois fois moins de six
ventes plastique d'acier vous n'y
arriverez pas uniquement par les prix là
c'est pareil il y aura des contraintes
réglementaires que vous allez devoir
mettre en place en ce qui concerne les
bâtiments
là c'est pareil si vous dites j'attends
que le prix du fuel monde pour que les
gens isolent leurs bâtiments vous y
serez jamais dans le bon ordre de
grandeur
donc là il faut obliger les
propriétaires à faire sinon ça marche
pas donc il faut passer par la
réglementation dont typiquement ce qu'on
commence à voir apparaître dans quelques
pays la grande bretagne a interdit le
renouvellement du fuel par dû soulager
plus qu'en 2022 2023 de danemark a fait
pareil
donc vous avez un certain nombre de pays
dans lesquels aujourd'hui par exemple il
est interdit de renouveler une chaudière
à fuel par une chaudière à fuel au
danemark il sera même interdit d'avoir
une chaudière à fuel à partir d'une
certaine année donc si vous en avez une
vous savez vous avez jusqu à l année
pour la remplacer par autre chose ça
c'est pas une mesure signal prix c'est
typiquement une mesure réglementaire bon
sens les bâtiments publics c'est
exactement pareil
le développement de la forêt là c'est là
j'ai envie de dire ces puits carbone
dont on a besoin pour séquestrer une
partie croissante de nos émissions c'est
pareil
un arbre il se passe entre soixante et
soixante ans et un siècle entre le
moment où il est planté et le moment où
il est coupé est ce que vous pensez
qu'on peut raisonnablement planifié 60 à
100 ans sur la base des prix de marché
de la semaine dernière
est ce que vous croyez raisonnablement
qu'on peut faire ça évidemment que non
est ce que vous pouvez faire ça sur la
base d'une promesse de modifier les prix
de marché sur les 50 ans qui viennent
avait quand même y regarder à deux fois
donc c'est typiquement des domaines dans
lesquels ça passera aussi par la
réglementation je vous donnais une
réglementation parmi d'autres possibles
vous allez peut-être la trouvais idiote
mais c'est juste pour illustrer mon
propos vous pouvez très bien dire
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus une parcelle
agricole qui ne soit pas abordée par une
aide d'au moins deux mètres d'épaisseur
avec des arbres de haute tige
voilà un exemple et bah ça c'est pas un
jeu par est un prix du co2 jusqu'au
moment où l'agriculteur va se dire tiens
c'est rentable pour moi de planter des
arbres j'ai juste lui dire c'est
obligatoire donc voilà c'est un exemple
je pourrais en prendre un autre
donc c'est là aussi un domaine dans
lequel le prix du co2 enfin à prix de
marché plus exactement c'est pas ça qui
va faire l'essentiel du job et enfin un
dernier point en ce qui concerne
l'alimentation
en gros si je prends je vous l'avais est
sorti au moment des émissions
l'empreinte carbone de l'alimentation
d'un français la moitié c'est le cheptel
bovin en ordre de grandeur
donc on ne fera pas l'économie d'avoir
moins de vaches si vous passez par les
prix de marché en voyage est taxé de
méthane
du coup le kilo de boeuf ou plus cher au
consommateur
mais le producteur ne gagne pas plus par
kilo de boeuf on est d'accord
donc si je monte les prix de marché
jusqu'au moment où le kilo de boeuf aux
deux fois plus cher pour le consommateur
ça veut dire que le producteur on lui en
achète on lui en achète deux fois moins
au même prix au kilo qu'aujourd'hui donc
de doubler le nombre de suicides et vous
désertifier encore plus les campagnes
la seule manière d'éviter ça c'est
d'encadrer les prix en sortie de ferme
est donc de dire aux producteurs je
t'achète ton kilo de boeuf trois fois
plus cher à condition qu'ils soient dans
les prés sans soja sans ogm mon projet
mais on s'en fout
etc
dans des prés dans lesquelles il ya des
essais
tu en auras deux fois moins je te le
pays trois fois plus cher et à ce moment
vous avez une équation qui est
totalement différent mais qui est
totalement impossible à mettre en place
sans réglementation de la gare système
de prix encadrés
ça s'appelle de la réglementation les
aoc les appellations d'origine contrôlée
c'est de la réglementation vous pouvez
pas faire du comté si vous n'êtes pas en
compte et avec du foin etc c'est
réglementaire d'accord et donc c'est une
protection réglementaire un type de
production qui permet de faire monter
les prix donc le donc dans l'agriculture
qu'il en ce sens là aussi des systèmes
très long et très long parce qu'en gros
vous changer les pratiques culturales au
renouvellement des générations c'est
comme ça que ça se passe
eh bien il est totalement impossible de
faire des choses dans le bon ordre de
grandeur en comptant uniquement sur 1,6
un signal prix qui serait taxée la
nuisance seul truc dont je suis à peu
près convaincu que ça marchera pas voilà
donc cessé alors encore une fois je suis
pas en train de vous vendre sa soupe
le but du jeu là c'est simplement de
prendre un certain nombre d'exemples
illustratif aussi un certain nombre
d'exemples illustratif dans lequel il
est assez facile de comprendre que de
passer par un signal prix uniquement
c'est quelque chose qui ne permet pas
quand vous regardez le secteur précis et
les acteurs précis du secteur ça ne
permet pas d'avoir l'ajustement du
système à la bonne vitesse sans que ça
craque de partout
oui
qui est ce facile
ça dépend ça peut être n'importe quoi ça
peut être décrets circulaires lois
directives
en gros c'est un une obligation de faire
ou une normalisation
voilà donc la grande question qui était
posée pendant ce court
c'est grâce à l'énergie abondante nous
avons eu çà et là question c'est est-ce
qu avec d'énormes économies on est
obligé de revenir à ça ou pas et vous
avez compris que la question reste pour
partie ouverte
alors j'ai quand même vous donner une
conclusion je ne crois pas à une
division par 2 ou 3 de la consommation
d'énergie dans le monde et à un maintien
du pib actuel personnellement j'y crois
pas dire que j'y crois parce que je suis
prêt à prendre le pari avec qui on a
envie en tout cas dans les 30 ans qui
viennent
mais tout autant c'est évident qu'on ne
coupera pas aux économies parce que au
plus tard au moment où
l'approvisionnement diminue pour des
raisons physiques
ces économies seront l'anc donc
j'insiste vraiment là-dessus
donc c'est pas quelque chose qui est du
ressort dont on fait ça par supplément
d'âme ou
simplement parce que ça ferait bien il
ya une vraie contrainte physique à gérer
et évidemment il faut se poser la
question de savoir comment on la gère
voilà à jeudi